e
you ready Mr Ripple okay um we're just
trying to make sure we got our clerking
responsibilities uh you you've got this
one representative wer yep okay so um
with being 10 o'clock we're going to
open a work session on division three uh
we're going to stick to the calendar and
go sequentially for those uh curious
about timing it's hard to predict how
how long each of these is going to take
um I um at the end also we're going to
invite some uh one-sided discussion on
on
s499 a a bill that division 3 dealt with
already and sent to the full finance
committee there's been ongoing
discussion with the Department that I
think we need to be aware of just
because it's going to go to the finance
committee later um without coming back
through division
three all right so um
I thank representative Mooney for uh
chairing our work session last time I
had uh a surgery on my nose and uh so I
think I'm ready to
go SB
352 um is a bill that uh establishes an
early detection cancer screening pilot
program for active and retired
firefighters I think the the high Lev on
this was that we had sort of
bipartisan um agreement that removing
skin cancer from the list was probably
the right way to go and that we had some
discussions about the cap um
representative
tersi did did you bring an amendment
forward and and in because I I also want
to get representa Leon to speak and
she's got like a bigger Amendment yep I
do have an amendment I can't remember if
it was distributed last time but it's
Amendment
760h it was distributed last time but I
have extra copies if anybody needs one I
I didn't get a copy but or or I didn't
keep track of a copy is probably more
accurate I'm not sure you were here to
chairman
1760 yep thank you oh yeah it looks
pretty
brief but if you want I can quickly
touch on what it highlight highlight
your Amendment please sure thing um so
this um was actually drafted based on um
the requested changes by the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire um which included um removing
the skin cancer
requirement which was in um on the
believe and then it
also
removes the
$1300 cap which if I'm looking at the
original Bill I'm going to try to find
it which I believe is on page two of the
original
Bill
line well no I think it's actually line
six
not to exceed the cost of
1300 line 14 on page two is going to
remain that section is reimbursement if
someone got a test on their own it will
still be capped at 1300 so my Amendment
only removes um the first mention of the
1300 oh I'm sorry sorry I didn't want to
interrupt you and I just wanted to point
out that it does maintain up to a $5
million expense for the entire program
to make sure that is rained in and and
doesn't go um you know over budget uh
for what we're looking at for the
program I think that's it may may I ask
you a question
sure
um do we already have in place a
reimbursement system that would handle
firefighters from around the state to
keep track of their spend and keep track
of what they're authorized for
reimbursement and can disperse money and
keep a record of what's been dispersed
do we already have that system I believe
that would be a question for others who
are um very involved with the program
perhaps uh Mr will okay is there anyone
that can address that question do we
have go
ahead uh say your name uh slowly uh for
the clerk oh you have it okay tell me
because I have a bad memory for the
record Brian re president of the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire and a fire captain in the city
of Portsmouth um thank you for your
question so the a a program similar to
this has been done in the state before
um through the department of safety um
there was a reimbursement program for
Life Scan physicals for retirees to get
a
comprehensive uh physical um nfba 158 2
physical and this occurred um within the
last uh I would say 5 years or so so the
the state has done a similar program in
the past how did that go did we did we
handle that reimbursement system well uh
who who was accountable for the system
and who was accountable for sort of the
fiduciary uh control and responsibility
I believe the department of safety was
the department of safety and they uh
when we asked them about the logistics
of this program
they said it's not a problem we've done
it before so is there anyone here from
the department of safety that could
verify that I mean I believe you I just
sure want to see if we can get kind of
an independent believe I've seen anyone
here this morning oh
okay all right um because that's
obviously a big deal right you know
launching a program and then finding out
if we don't really have the system to do
it all but um all right uh I'm going to
I'm going to go on your word and say
it's been done the department has said
it's okay um all right so representative
Leon did you did you have anything
further you wanted to say on your
Amendment no I think that's good I'll if
I have more to share I will okay
representative Leon uh yes thank you Mr
chairman uh Mr Ripple has the amendment
that I had drafted um we got it just
this morning there is one small error
that I'm seeing the second part actually
was supposed to insert a new section B
in sub paragraph v um and it shouldn't
be replacing the current one that one
should the the current sub paragraph B
should exist that's the expenditure of
funds not being made available for more
than 24 months after the approval okay
let's hang on until we get the copy of
your Amendment and I'll need probably 20
seconds to skim it okay
thank
you thank
done so um if I I can wait just a second
I'm I'm sorry I'm my lip are moving that
okay all right I'm ready thanks okay
thank you um so my concern is over the
language in the vendor preference um
because it specifically says a
multi-cancer blood test that detects
signals from as many cancer types as
possible including those that are
commonly unscreened we've had a lot of
discussion about one specific test
that's seen some pretty significant
adoption at some cancer centers near us
but if you actually look at that
language and see and read it
specifically it says from as many cancer
types as possible there are some other
tests that are in development that have
more cancers that are detected but at a
lower accuracy rate than the one that is
preferred by the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire having
this language in may actually make it
harder for them to have the preferred
test if there are other tests that test
for more cancers at a lower accuracy
rate removing that vendor preference
wouldn't prohibit them from including
that test in the screening program
because in the language um for a um I I
retain the blood test I change it
exactly the same as representative
tarki's um section A so that language
onlines for through six of mine is
exactly the same as the language of
lines 3 through five of her Amendment so
um including continuing to include a
blood test would still allow for that
test to be part of this program and to
be adopted it simply would not require
that the the the way that it's done um
looking at this so that's the first part
is that this this may actually not
permit the test that is preferred to be
chosen in the vendor preference because
there are some tests that screen for
more cancers so it's just an issue of
the language the other part is that I I
I intended can can you hold there yes I
had a little bit of trouble following
you because I'm looking at the amendment
language and I'm not sure which
sentences um create the the balance
between screening for maximum cancers
while
minimizing false positives is there is
there language in here that does that or
because it sounded like you think there
is but I'm not seeing it no there's um
thank you for that question there's not
actually any language that does that my
Amendment on lines 7 through n um
basically deletes lines 9 and 10 of the
original Bill and collapses um line
eight with lines 11 through 13 so that
there there's vendor preference for the
ultrasound test um I simply make it so
that it's silent I think that if uh we
were to continue to have language um if
were to keep number one it should have
language to balance the accuracy with
the number of tests that are included
because there's been discussion about
the fact that there are others um
representative Stringham actually has
some pretty significant experience with
another test that has a higher that has
a strong accuracy rate but only for 12
types of cancers um there are there are
quite a few that are in development and
um that's why that's why having some
having that language may cause a problem
so if I can just give you a little bit
of background on that MD Anderson which
is one of the big cancer centers in New
York says um there's currently around 20
tests in development they offer
screening for anywhere from two to over
50 tumor types in a single test some of
the cancers the test can detect include
pancreatic prostate kidney lung breast
skin ovarian and liver cancer so there's
a lot of these in development and if
we're not careful about this language
that prioritizes the vendors we may
actually Force the decision to go with a
lower quality test because of that and
knowing the strong preference for having
one of these blood tests if it's not
otherwise available to the
firefighters removing that from the
vendor preference doesn't mean that
there's not a significant likelihood
that it will that this this test or one
like this will be included if it's not
otherwise available to Firefighters but
we're not locking in um language that
could lead to bad policy because it may
force them to adopt something other than
the gallery test that's being used at MD
Anderson and Mass General Hospital so um
this this is a way of removing language
that may be a problem um the other and
so does that make sense there it it it
it it does I had a different question
for you on your Amendment okay are you
ready um if it's in that se because I I
interrupted you when you finished one
point did you want to continue with your
second point I was going to talk about
the other section if your questions
about this section we should have it now
no I'm I'm I would ask you about sort of
this third SE section that I'm not
really seeing and that's representative
Tori uh on her Amendment on lines 9 and
10 uh makes it clear that firefighters
will have the option do do we if if we
were to go with the bulk of your
amendment should we in your opinion pick
up lines nine and 10 from the tersi
amendment is is is that is that an
important part to to this program um
well thank you the language that's in
there is already optional but the tersi
amendment removes the cap what my
section there does is it looks to insert
in a separate section so that if the
screening costs are less than
$1,300 um a firefighter would be able to
be reimbursed for any of the other
diagnostic testing that needs to be done
to follow up either from this blood test
or the lung CT or from the ultrasounds
because follow-up tests are not covered
under Insurance regularly um if there is
a finding we just pass a bill in the
house that makes it so that the
follow-up testing for mammograms when
there is a signal found or in a
screening that that is covered under
insurance so so yes ma'am I I think you
answered a question but it wasn't the
one I thought I was asking okay okay so
on lines nine and 10 of the tersi
amendment it says firefighter
participation in cancer screening shall
be optional and a firefighter shall be
eligible to receive any combination of
off offered screenings so so the thing
that jumps out at me that's distinct in
her Amendment from yours is she has
specific language that says the
firefighter participation is optional so
my question to you is if we went with
the bulk of your amendment should we
bring from the tersi amendment the
option for firefighters to participate
um I'm not changing section I'm not
changing those lines in the original
bill so my Amendment doesn't touch um
paragraph uh 5 a and I have no problem
with that um when I add in the other one
just like the reimbursement section
that's in paragraph six that allows a
reimbursement up to 1300 by offering the
reimbursement including the other
followup test up to 1300 it's consistent
policy-wise while helping with the out-
of- pocket costs right so let me go to
you representative torki you you you put
in your Amendment lines nine and 10 for
a reason if this isn't changing the
underlying Bill why why is it here I'm
assuming it does change the underlying
Bill my language is in the underlying
bill on page two of the bill lines six
and 7 yeah all I did was remove the
words let me make sure I get it
right on page six I remove the words not
to exceed a cost of $1,300 per
individual
okay okay
so these two these two bills amendments
are compatible they're not in Conflict
they're not there's not a gap here I'm
just trying to make sure we got a good
merger I don't I'm not particularly
jumping into a
merger I know I'm I am though I'm just
trying to see if if they they should be
merged and if they did what it would
take to make sure that the intent of
your your bill is is carried over this
section I have haven't dug into very
deeply on the Layon Amendment but I do
have some concerns on the um removal of
the multi-cancer blood test language so
um I'm still
digesting this second part okay okay so
the it seems to me
that if we don't have language in here
that
basically says that we need to avoid
tests as much as possible that have an
unreasonable false positive rate will
end up sending firefighters into the
screening getting a false positive in
many many
cases causing family
anxiety and then additional cost of the
program so so how how are you
balancing uh good tests to ident
identify
screening from avoid and avoid while
avoiding tests that create an
unnecessarily high level of false
positives um so what I the way I intend
to do that is actually partly outside of
the legislative process I've already
begun speaking been begun trying to
arrange meetings um with with with
oncologists from Dartmouth we have one
that'll be speaking at a lunch next
Wednesday from 12: to 1 about biomarkers
and this is related to biomarkers um in
order to arrange a clinical trial of New
Hampshire firefighters looking at the
additional benefit from this test in
addition to the ex ex these other
standard screening tests to see how much
more cancer it finds and how much more
of a benefit it finds because right now
this test isn't it's not approved by the
FDA yet because they're still doing
studies for approval it's not
recommended by any medical societies
it's not reimbursed by anybody although
there is efforts so that it will be
immediately covered upon FDA approval
for medic Medicare um it's important to
know how much of a benefit it has and
because firefighters are at increased
risk it's very important to know how
much more benefit it provides to them
it's quite possible they may see a
greater benefit from this than the
average person but we don't know that
and nobody will know that without data
so the American Cancer Society and the
International Association of
firefighters work together on screening
guidelines New Hampshire could actually
lead the way if we do actual study to
see how much benefit there is so that
that can become adopted for firefighters
across the country we have our own
Center of clinical and research
Excellence at Dartmouth and we have
several south of our border at Dana
Farber and Mass general doctors love to
do research and it's easy to get both
that it's easier to get that test and
the follow-up screenings required to get
the data needed for that study paid for
by other people so it won't be paid out
of pocket by the firefighters if they're
in that study which will benefit them
get them the information they need and
be able to help them have better
outcomes and help them help their
brothers across the country to know the
data and know that know if this is a
test that is actually going to going to
be a strong benefit right so so what I'd
like to do is because I I think this is
the first time we've had a chance to see
this text um I I would like to go ahead
and uh basically pause further
discussion on
352 and uh that way when we we can we'll
recess for lunch or something and then
so folks can on a onetoone basis have
this discussion uh not we can't meet
with a quorum but we can talk it through
um and then we'll come back this
afternoon and figure out you know how we
would execute or how what we would
recommend that that's my proposal is
there and I apologize to the fire
firefighters who've showed up that this
is um not not going to U be immediately
gratifying to you but I but I think I
would encourage you H to have some
confidence in this process we all sort
of are aligned on the idea that I
believe we are we're all aligned on the
idea that firefighters do because of the
inhaling of tox and exposure to toxic
materials while conducting a very vital
Public Safety function that we have an
obl ation um uh to uh help you screen
and protect against it and we're trying
to figure out how to do it in a way in
which um uh the program is effective and
that we're not locking in language that
will lock in Vendor choices over the
long term we need this language to
breathe so that new medical technology
comes out we can adapt to it so uh so we
want to be careful there yes yes ma'am I
think we would be um fine with sitting
on it for a little bit and um having
some conversations at lunch but I did
want to take the time to acknowledge and
thank the very large number of
firefighters who are here the people who
are watching at home maybe they
obviously cannot see um the large
turnout that we have and I want to thank
them for their advocacy in this um and
bringing this forward so thank you very
much Mr chair all right I I I agree
representative Mooney thank you very
much Mr chair I too have an amend mment
it's number 1869 H and while we're on
the topic of Senate Bill
352 I figure we go over this so that
when everyone breaks to discuss uh they
will have all of the amendments in front
of them and I'll be glad to explain what
okay I I think I think I'm caught up
yours Amendment varies uh as I if I'm as
I'm looking at it a little from
representative
toris uh with the uh lines three of hers
and the line three of yours from there
on down that's a that's a little
different and that uh lines nine and 10
if I'm reading it right they're
identical your your nine and 10 is the
same as toki's nine and 10 that's true
okay so why don't you tell us about the
distinction you're making in lines three
through five okay thank you Mr chairman
so my amendment is based off of the
tersi amendment number 1760
it struck me while reading the original
bill that on
lines five through seven on page one and
I brought this up at our work session on
Tuesday there's a word and in there so
it proceeds to list the cancer screening
options and it uses the word and that to
me reads that all of these are required
so my Amendment instead clarifies by
saying any combination of one or more of
the following
tests and that is specific in my
Amendment lines 4 and five is where that
inserted language appears any
combination of one or more of the
following tests this then to me reads as
though you know maybe one test is uh
preferred or required but the other's
not a clarifier from the original
language then the second part of my
Amendment basically does the same thing
in that section Roman 5 lowercase a
thank you okay so I I need to sum this
up so I'm tracking with you um it looks
like uh lines 4 through six of the Layon
amendment is uh is the same as yours or
not no I like hers better though I've
not you like hers better yes okay and
then uh her or uh the lay on Amendment
adds lines 7 through n that yours does
not do you do you how do you react to
the Layon lines 7 through n if we were
to try to merge all of these would would
we want to pick up the lay on 7 through
nine I haven't uh fully done a side by
side of mine Amendment with hers so I
would um have to think about that but my
in my Amendment naturally the Layon
language lines 7 through n is not
included so I don't get into to vendors
specific or false positive um innuendos
mine is a clarifier that you may need
one or two tests but certainly not a a
Full Slate required love that part I
love that part I'm just trying to U on
the Fly get grasp what we're going to do
here we have three amendments that I
think improves the bill but rather than
have three amendments we should just try
to figure out if we could create
one that that's what I'm trying to do
understood okay I would wait on that
considering my was made right represent
tki addition to the tersi amend I just
wanted to acknowledge that at first read
I like the Mooney Amendment a lot I
think it does clarify um and I was just
wondering though if there's a chance Mr
will could return to the mic and just
give us his perspective on it um because
I know that there was some discussion
back and forth on the language
Choice sure uh I I I just am curious if
we've offered him enough opportunity to
see all of this and have an opportunity
to integrate it and take a position so
quickly um thank you and if you can you
should become a
legislator well I I just so happened to
know that um there were some similar
amendments coming because we did discuss
it in the last meeting um so this isn't
uh really the first time we're hearing
about it um I thank representative
Mooney representative tersi and
representative Leon for for putting some
thought into this um representative
Mooney and representative tarki's
Amendment combined um would be exactly
what the fire lki and Mooney yep would
be exactly amendments that we would be
looking for um for this testing again
it's already been vetted out in multiple
committees it's already gone through
multiple floor votes um what I think is
important to draw a conclusion from is
the fact that we're not uh handcuffing
the state of New Hampshire for a
long-term screening process that is
going to include any specific vendors or
any specific tests the idea here is to
cast a wide net to test for as many
cancers as possible so that we can
further identify how we need to um bring
the guard rails in for the future but
this is just a one-time funding
opportunity we're not asking for the
State of New Hampshire to expend funds
in perpetuity for any uh given test this
is just uh these tests and uh the
Amendments from representative uh tki
and representative Mooney um are what we
are looking for um to identify cancers
amongst our members so you're being very
diplom itic what what is it if anything
that you uh think the lay on Amendment
adds that's positive that's positive yes
we don't need to do the negatives fair
enough
um I'm struggling to identify something
represent all right well so we are going
to you know do launch and stuff and you
you could maybe look at that a little
deeper okay M all right go ahead
represent leam um thank you Mr chairman
and I know you've just had this in front
of you um I I'd ask that you look to the
section that would allow reimbursement
for any any follow-up screening tests
because I know at least one of the
firefighters in Manchester had to pay
out of pocket for a followup after his
lung CT and I want to be sensitive to
that cost for our firefighters so I'm
not putting you on the spot for an
answer but I I I thought that that would
be helpful one right right that's that
sounds to me to be a very positive thing
if I were a firefighter that we're going
to screen and then if the screening is
positive then we're going to be there to
help cover the cost of follow-up
treatment to get a definitive diagnosis
rather than having that followup be out
of pocket or right is that is that is
that what you're trying to do that is
the specific intent so thank you
representative um I would say that in
most cas and I'm unaware of the case
that you're you're speaking of but in
most cases um if there is a cancer
identified through one of these tests or
a cancer signal and they were to get
follow-up testing um a PCP would be able
to give a referral based on that testing
and in fact would be covered um so I'm
less concerned about that what I'm more
concerned about is that it attaches back
the $1300 cap um which I don't
anticipate that a follow-up test
in addition to the screening will be
under the $1,300 cap so I'm hesitant to
add that back in and that's what we're
trying to remove with the tersi and M
amendments okay so I I'm I I missed your
turn there you you you you I think your
position
is you're not as concerned about us
paying for the follow-up care because it
sounds like the regular health insurance
and the Health Care system will take
care of followup if there's a positive
POS screen so you're not really
concerned about this bill covering the
followup costs is that I think I think
in a perfect world if there was
unlimited funds then that would then
that would be a realistic uh ask but
understanding that this is a pilot
program only there's a $5 million cap on
it um we want to make sure that our
members get screened and that money um
is is allowing us to cast the wide net
um I do believe in many cases our
follow-up care would be covered through
our insurance companies and further
sorry what um Dr Hamrock had testified
to the other day um was was if there is
in fact a positive test um that is then
attached to the insurance company and
they own that there would be no
additional cost right so so the
distinction is you you don't want a
$1,300 cap and it's been proposed
correct
okay anything else I don't believe so do
you have questions representative tki
I'm good thank you I appreciated him
taking a look at them all okay so it was
a lot thrown at you and we'll we'll be
back this afternoon on this okay thank
you so so I I think I think we're ready
to move on to the next bill uh and we'll
do I Mr Ripple do I have to recess 352
or or is it still within the same work
session I think it's they're all noticed
for the the same time so it's still
within the same work session all right
355 relative to newborn screening of a
very long
c-word um cyal La
virus very nice show off hey thanks for
coming we got your back we just need to
okay is I I have a note that says Mr
Ripple will get an
amendment representa Mooney yes I'd like
to introduce an amendment to Senate Bill
355 based on our discussions last
Tuesday at the work session it's
amendment number
1878 H and I'd like to speak to that
Amendment it shouldn't be a surprise
because uh the topics came up during our
work session Tuesday thank you
okay do you want to well let's let's
follow protocol and give people a chance
all right I think I think I'm ready for
you to get into this if if you want to
expand thank you this bill has undergone
several changes uh as it started in the
Senate and then came over to the house
it came out in our work session Tuesday
that two sections were missing as it
came to us and so I put them back in the
first is in the first section of my
Amendment and you'll notice specifically
on line8 it includes the May opt out of
the screenings
provision so we're putting that back in
May opt
out the second piece was the education
piece we may recall the uh audiologist
who spoke to us on Tuesday and she
specifically brought this out and that
is uh to provide the Department of
Health and Human Services shall provide
information on the importance of early
detection of cyto megla meglo virus so
that now would be put back in the bill
so I would ask for support on this uh as
we' mentioned uh the fiscal note is
extraordinarily minimal and then I would
ask for ought to pass with Amendment
motion after that thank you all right so
so I think we can discuss
I I um I would like to know if anyone in
the room knows which professional
Society is is is the one most likely to
disease I I have a note that says it was
documented so initially in my
conversations with the Department uh
they noted that this would require 20%
of a full-time equivalent position at a
cost of $26,000 now typically as an
office our practice is if a bill isn't
going to result in a new position being
filled uh we say there's no fiscal
impact So based on the 20% estimate I
assume there would be no fiscal impact
um it sounds like based on the
Department's test testimony earlier this
week it might not be quite what I had in
mind it sounds like it's a 50% of a
position so a part-time of which the
general fund share would be 20% um so I
think it would be fair to revise this
fiscal note to say there's a $226,000
cost but I haven't yet done that all
right all right thank you so so let's
you're going to get an opportunity after
you introduce yourself to talk to
whatever you want I I want I do want to
get to my question though sure I'm Abby
Rogers legislatively ason for the
division of Public Health Services and
I'm Courtney Keane with public health
Courtney all right so um so I don't know
how we're all tiered but I imagine that
there is a a professional society that
that focuses on this and worries about
this who who is that what what
organization would that
be so there's a two-tier so the New
Hampshire Hospital Association because
the hospitals would be conducting the
test is that your question of
financially no like uh is it
nephrologists is it
endocrinologists you know who there must
be some you know Medical Professional
society that has this diagnosis kind of
in their
purview yes audiologists audiologist
audiologist aist well in in the focus of
this Bill yes but overall would be the
American Academy of Pediatrics and also
Maternal Fetal Medicine Specialists
because there is congenital CMV which is
passed from Mom to Baby so that would be
a Maternal Fetal OBGYN or pediatrician
or as Courtney said um for the resulting
hearing loss that can occur with CMV
Audiology Society so so I'm I'm just I'm
focusing on U represent Presa Mooney's
part of the bill that starts on line
nine and goes through 15 um directing
the department to to take on kind of a
form of educational role and uh and two
things come to mind one if there's a
professional society that has this as
part of their you know medical
scope those professional societies are
responsible for figuring out how to do
CME and how to communicate within the
profession to let people know and be
aware of problems
so so that's my understanding is if if
that's correct uh then the
responsibility for creating information
about this and communicating it to the
provider Community is already in place I
think am I you you you can you can
disagree with me I I'm I'm just telling
what I think is the
case uh sure I mean individual societies
do communicate um on the incidents of
CMV but as this is diagnosed in infants
it's usually um pediatricians or the
American academ Academy of Pediatrics
that would draw attention to the
incidence of CMV there this piece of it
in line nine um would be the the long
short story is that CMV is not
recommended for for inclusion under the
newborn screening program so for the New
Hampshire State panel we don't currently
screen for CMV as part of that program
as a result there is a high there is an
incidence in CMV there are mixed uh
clinical recommendations that there
should be more education around the
incidents of CMV both with providers and
with parents so this section in line
nine was added in our work communicating
with Senator inis on his desire to have
uh more education for new parents for
parents that may be thinking about
having children this is out there that
this is something that your child could
be diagnosed with because it's not
something that we would officially adopt
through the newborn screening program we
do provide information on a variety of
other conditions that affect newborns
and so we worked with him on on that
section to say what we would be happy to
contribute some more um education to
Providers to parents on the on CMV if if
we remove section nine what what is your
estimate of the Manpower required to to
uh comply with the bill and the
amendment that starts on lines 3 through
eight
so it would still be0 2 of a05 FTE and
it's mainly because working with the
hospitals to get them up and running
with CMV testing and then for them to
report to the state the screening
results so that's where the Manpower is
the educ ation is an additional
component um it would be intertwined
with the development with the hospitals
on their protocols for screening for
CMV yeah so my my reluctance to embrace
the education component is I don't know
that the state has the expertise and the
ongoing continuing updates of ongoing
research in order to be remain flexible
and Nimble on what that education should
be and and this is why I think
historically professional societies have
owned the responsibility of developing
CME and priorities and conferences in
Las Vegas and that sort of thing so so I
I'm I'm a little reluctant to to to to
do the education component uh
representative tki thanks I'm just
wondering if I could ask you said that
regularly they educate on other things
during newborn screenings can you give
us an idea of what that is and if this
is literally just going to be another
add-on to a conversation or a flyer or
whatever that would help me understand
yeah so right now the hospitals um OB
providers all receive a flyer uh
pamphlet brochure of all the screenings
that are conducted in New Hampshire it's
a snapshot of what's done so it provides
a little bit of information on the
overall screenings that are done it
would be embedded into this it is
updated every so often it is not an
indepth
educational material it is just an FYI
this is what's going to happen to your
baby blah blah blah and that's provided
to parents yes okay that helps me a lot
um in one of my pregnancies I um had I
was flagged for something that a
screening found and I at first was a
little nervous did some research even
without a robust internet back then um
understood it better pursued it and
educated myself and in the end
everything was fine but I think that
having that kind of resource available
to parents um is is a valuable uh tool
to actually have it all in that one uh
document so I would encourage um
maintaining the education
section uh thank you for that I I think
I think that implies that there's only
one source of these pamphlets I'm I'm
Pro education I'm Pro parental awareness
you know I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm Pro all of
those things I'm just looking at the you
know the efficacy over the long run of
whether or not the state is as Nimble as
it needs to be to keep a pamphlet up to
date so I would argue that one piece of
information even if it's brief bullet
points that incompass the whole Spectrum
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
versus seven to eight different little
Flyers that you know if they all get
compiled at once um that one document is
going to be far more effective um than a
bunch of others um that one may may be
about um an issue that maybe isn't as
concerning as another one but due to
graphic design or publishing choices or
whatever this other one may seem more
confusing more prominent whatever I just
I don't know I feel that if they're
already doing it I don't see
the trouble in adding one more bullet
point on are are you the only source of
U pamphlets to educate
parents uh I would say that they're
probably um any OBGYN office or
pediatrician may have pamphlets um for
for parents that are expecting babies
and where do those pamphlets get who who
owns the keeping those current and
published I would assume that the
societies would do that I I think what
we're talking about with um education
might be as simple as what is CMV on our
website just for a general awareness
that this is out there and if um babies
fail two hearing tests and or tests for
CMV this could um prevent uh further
language delays due to hearing loss from
this
condition well I'm anti- hearing
loss uh so okay so you've you've heard a
lot of discussion about your education
component what do you what do you
think um I still want would like to make
a motion to introduce Amendment 1878 H
all right we've been okay is there a
second second okay
um oh Earth because she's a sub it's one
of the rules all right but we can make
all right I I we can't but uh so what
else would you like to tell us about
this amendment before I sent yes okay
representative Le on um thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to ask one more
question of the department if that
education would also include that for
babies with hearing loss and a positive
CMV antiviral treatment could May
reverse that hearing loss I think that
would probably be in the scope of a p
utrition uh information that they would
we would we'd be talking about what is
CMV general information about CMV any
clinical guidelines would definitely go
back to the provider societies to
provide for patients okay thank you I I
thought that was the most important
thing but it's important to know that
know that that's how you see it thank
you thank
you yeah question yes so CMV early
detection is it quickly cured or is this
and if it's not do it lead to more
long-term damage or or what's the
importance of this is this something you
find it out you can take care of it
quickly or if you don't find out it
might be a year or two before you get
into it and then it's worse that's a
great question um I don't know the
answer in its entirety I will say the
sooner that it's detected the faster the
treatment can begin um for hearing loss
in particular if you catch it early
they'll screen the child and do
diagnostic testing more frequently to
reduce the hearing loss as the child
you I I I think we're we're ready to uh
get get a sense if since this is an
amendment I think we could do a show of
hands good uh show a hands on who
approves this amendment those
opposed all right six to nothing I
abstained Mr I didn't vote no I I I'm
really I'm I'm just really ambivalent
about stepping on a professional Society
who's built to for this purpose yes
ma'am do you want to say something it's
already passed by the way so so it has
to be really brilliant because we've
it oh come on up tell us I teach me
something
this is probably the letter this is
Carol dry yes thank you um good morning
chairman Edwards members of the
committee my name is Elizabeth Sergeant
champan Capital group here representing
the New Hampshire Academy of Audiology
we've been working with Abby and
Courtney k at DHHS we have sub submitted
testimony to this committee um and I
guess I will read one sentence to you
according to CDC surveys only one in 10
women of childbearing age have ever
heard of it so we certainly support the
Department's idea that we would just add
it to the um information about it and
audiologists certainly would be part of
the process after it would get diagnosed
at the hospital if they feel a fail a
hearing test so we appreciate uh your
support all right so go ahead and make
it 7
nothing all all right thank you thank
you very
much all right uh so so now we have to
go on the underlying bill and I think we
need um a vote on this right so are we
going to uh have a motion to adopt or
recommend adoption to the finance
committee of s SP 355 with Amendment uh
1878 I can make that motion okay so I'd
make a motion of ought to pass with
Amendment like you said with amendment
number
1878 h a
second okay so do how how how should we
do this represent wer do you want to
actually have us
vote um I should actually call a role
representative priest probably should
not vote because he just walked he
wasn't here when the question was put
yeah I I don't have the uh the list but
I look I'll look around and figure it
go representative
Mooney
yes representative wer votes yes
representative F
yes uh representative Leon
yeah representative wner
yes representative tki
yes I guess we're leaving PRI he wasn't
here when the question was put so
representative Edwards yes 70 passes all
right thank thank you um so we're moving
on to S
sp404 relative to expanding child care
professionals eligibility for the child
program my notes
suggest that uh representative walner
was possibly working on an
amendment okay do you want to and then M
Mr Ripple you were ALS is is your the
amendment you were working on the same
is hers I have two amendments for this
one for representative walner and one
for representative money okay why don't
no that's all right so so so I'm going
to I'm going to do this um the other way
I'm going to ask representative Mooney
to talk to her Amendment because it's
pretty short and and then and then we'll
talk about representative walner and
a a combined
discussion what what what representative
Mooney would you like to speak to your
Amendment thank you Mr chair yes uh so
I'm going to talk on Amendment 1859 9h
however it is my intention to amend this
amendment and so I am going to talk on
behalf of that amended Amendment and
I'll explain why I I think you need to
the amended amendment I say that again
all right I'll do that I'll do it this
way in the amendment in front of you
1859 H it is my intention to put in an
additional amendment to change the date
on line 15
from November 1st
2024 to November 1st
2025 okay I
understand this the lines prior to that
date so all the rest of the bill is
essentially the version that came from
the
Senate as you recall this bill has
changed dramatically from the Senate to
the house the Senate version as in in
front of you is the establishment of a
child care Workforce child care
assistance pilot program period with
well for my purposes period And so from
there you know all of the specifications
of that including what will be my
amended deadline of November 1
2025 the house go ahead the house
version implements the program with a
price tag of approximately 2.5 million
or
thereabouts my Amendment again reverts
us back to the Senate version at no cost
with a change in date of the report due
and that is the amendment I would like
to propose thank you okay qu just a
question for you if we if if um as my
old project management days um if if you
were going to do a pilot project it was
important to know kind of the start date
and the end date because they're
temporary right so you got to have an
end date are you do you think that this
bill given the fact that there's a
report due makes it clear that there's
an end date to the pilot project yes
absolutely all right all right so so
you're reverting you're basically
reverting back to the Senate bill and
the policy committee got into outside of
policy and added money so yes they did
so um they're they're not they're
supposed to do policy and and not money
as I'm told
frequently um but representative walner
go
yeah so well the one question I have
about the
report representative Mooney's amendment
is that I'm not sure what the department
would be reporting on if no pilot
program was going
forth I'm not sure what kind of
information or data they would
be collecting actually I mean it it's a
report on a program that doesn't exist
so that that's a little cumbersome to me
with that one so but what um my
Amendment would
do
is it would um provide provide for an a
percentage income guideline that um
you'll see on line four of the amendment
that um households with an income less
than 500% of the federal poverty level
um would be those that were eligible no
one over that would be
eligible um the next part of it is in
the original Bill the
um in the if you went back to the
original bill that was introduced I
think the
um appropriation was
2.2
million to run the
program and what I have done is on line
24 um basically reduce that to 1 million
and the reason for the reduction of the
1 m to the 1 million is that the program
would not start until January one of
2025 so it would run for six months
cycle yeah you'll see it I was looking
for it too I couldn't figure out where
it went to it's under effective dat
effective date okay so it would it would
start on January 1 which really I think
gives the
department since something like this is
probably not going to be passed and
signed until in July or you know it will
take the department time to set this up
I also in here in this Amendment provide
that the department can um contract this
out so that it's not um it's not the
department that would have to run this
particular program they could contract
it out and I put in
$100,000 for the administration of the
program they may choose to do it
themselves or they may contract it out
this probably is not going to be a
major major program it's only going to
really address the needs of very few
people and if I'll just remind you what
it was what it is
about so as you know
um child
care has had a very difficult time
recruiting and retaining their
Workforce and they've been looking
for ways of finding incentives to get
people into get people into the field
and retain them in the
field and this is basically offers just
an another tool in their toolbox of
things that they can do to get people to
look at child care as a
profession
um it's probably is not going to be
something that there will be a huge
number of people that will fall into
this category but certainly any number
will be good and you you know that we've
seen numbers of bills here and we've
certainly from being on fiscal we've
seen a lot of um groups coming forward
to us looking for things like loan
forgiveness for their professions U
bonuses for their professions I mean all
kinds of things to try to encourage
Workforce so this is just a another
Workforce retention and
um retaining the workforce we have
or getting you know getting new people
to come into the
workforce um questions about the
amendment I I I do but I I want to make
sure uh representative Stringham welcome
back uh we have representative wer who's
taking clerk notes on this so you you
can relax for this one because he's got
that okay uh I I I I do have um some
questions for you representative walner
uh and that is um what what how would
you describe the employment category of
those that would be eligible for this
scholarship what I mean you you use the
term profession
professional what what usually the word
professional implies some sort of a
certification or training qualification
or you know what what could you can you
describe the the the employment category
uh and what makes it a profession well
child care um providers do have
requirements that they have to meet um
under State licensing requirements so
they can come in with a fairly minimum
amount of um professional development
but as they move through the um career
lattice they have to have more and more
education and um meet a higher standard
of Licensing so is there a minimum level
of Licensing that we're going to require
uh for this scholarship is there is
there I I I have I I got to tell you I
I'm I'm behind on reading the underlying
bill so I'm leaning on you for this a
little bit is there is there no there
was not there was not a minimum so it it
could be someone at the very
beginner you know a someone who is a
beginner um and would come into a child
care center and uh be an assistant or a
teacher Aid
um this is not just for the teachers
this is for a CH any child care provider
level so the intent is to offer the
scholarships only to people that are
getting into Child Care yes thank you
exactly and what what are they doing
that requires a scholarship are they
they're a child they have a child who
needs to go to the word scholarship
isn't really the right word a
scholarship is a tuition scholarship for
the child so that the child can be in
child care
well in most cases the mother is working
in child care okay so when I read
scholarship I'm thinking a professional
is going to school and needing a
scholarship this is really a subsidized
Child Care fee exactly child
Child Care Subsidy is called the child
care scholarship program all right all
right thank you for the education I
understand I understand the confusion F
500% of
FPL is is what that's like 200,000 isn't
it I mean that's a no it no what what
what do you think 500% works out to be
get a family of four was about
85 for 500% though
um M Ripple can I ask you a trivia
question what what would for a family of
four are you able to give me a estimate
for what 500% of FPL is yes so for a
family of four assuming the numbers that
I'm looking at are current So based on
2024 income numbers family of four the
federal poverty level level is 31,200 so
500% would be
156,000 Say Say That
156,000 156
okay so so for a family making
156,000 we would
subsidize Child Care go ahead represent
torki I was just going to
say for a parent who works in a child
care setting so this is like a double
incentive program to
expand the teachers or the child care
providers they can attract workers to
come in by doing so say I say you have
um a mom who left the work forced to
have a child she now has a 2-year-old
she needs to go to go back to work she
needs child care so that's sort of like
a you know it it where can she get
affordable child care um well this
program would allow her to get a job as
a child care provider in a licensed
professional
setting and she would get a partial um
scholarship or the word we could say
let's call it um a tuition grant for the
child to help pay for that child in
child care at her employer's office at
her employer excuse me yeah so that
allows them to open up more spaces for
other children let's say I don't know
what the ratio is but let's say that
allows the center to bring in four more
children that allows four more other
families to bring their children and it
opens up spaces um one of the big
challenges we have with our Workforce is
people aren't going back to work cuz
there's no spots to put their children
in child care so by
incentivizing um these jobs by saying
you can have this job as a child care
provider and we'll give you this you
qualify to care for your own child in
the program um it's sort of a like a
Snowball Effect to help try to attempt
to assist the workforce challenges and
the child care uh problems we have in
the state
okay great explanation thank you
government is really good we can manage
all of that I'm sure um so can you tell
me is this a a pilot project or is this
a permanent
program well it this would provide
funding to start the program for six
months and at the end of the six months
we'd be in the budget cycle and I assume
that the department would and it does
require still a report the department
would report as to how the program is
working how many people have been
recruited how many people have stayed in
the field I mean there'd be a time for
Gathering all that kind of information
and we would you know like everything
else have to come to the budget process
and look to continue the program or you
know maybe not continue it if it hasn't
been
successful so it um we took out the word
pilot because um in the CH special child
care committee the word
pilot there were members who didn't feel
they wanted to call it a pilot so that
that part was taken out they didn't like
the word or they didn't like the concept
no they didn't like the word
pilot it's my favorite word okay well
okay oh they love those kinds of Pilots
but they um so we the word pilot came
out the other thing that did get added
in the um Child Care committee was um
that the Department of Health and Human
Services would ask the federal
government for a waiver to allow for
this to be funded through federal
funds so that's in that's in the bill as
it came from the special child care
committee okay so not that you would
advocate for one but if you were U
compelled to to stick your finger on a
Sunset
date what what what Sunset date might
you
consider well I think it would I think
it I think just because of the funding
it automatically sort of sunsets on June
[Music]
3025 because
it's it's not funded past that so so
this was this was I think I I tried to
asked this in an earlier
question um is this a is this a pilot or
a different word or is this a permanent
this is going permanent into the program
experiment an
experiment um I have no objection
personally to the word pilot program
okay okay it was other members of the
special child care committee that
objected to it and it seemed like
it it seemed like something not to fight
about the bill right um because of that
one word all right so so you think that
this is clearly an exp a self-expiring
program though I do I do and I think it
it's if it's successful it may make it
into the budget it may not be successful
so I'm going to ask Mr Ripple what what
do you think because of the funding on
this is this a self-expiring ing program
or or are we reading this into permanent
law and and therefore the department is
going to be obligated to submit a budget
for
it go ahead it says the funds are
non-lps non laap that ises not apply an
endpoint but but when we make a
permanent requirement the department
gets compelled to submit a budget to
cover the things the legislature directs
them to do I think and so I just want to
make sure that the department wouldn't
be compelled to submit a budget if uh
this a line item for this if uh as
written it would enact the program in
statute so I think the expectation is
that it would be ongoing I think to
representative walner point every
ongoing Pro uh program is ultimately
subject to the budget process so yes the
department would include it in its
budget requests but it would be up to
the governor and the legislature to
decide whether or not to fund it yeah
okay but this program isn't going to
have isolated accounting it's going to
be buried in all the other lines of
accounts and and so is having gone
through a couple of budget Cycles I
don't know that we would have visibility
into uh the the the incremental funding
that gets associated with this program I
I I would feel better about your
Amendment if we put an explicit Sunset
date in it and that way if we like the
program uh we can uh reauthorize the
program but if we put it in the statute
we're essentially telling the department
requests what do you think I think I
think that um if if that's how you would
feel comfortable with passing this
particular piece of legislation I think
that would that would work for me are
there are there comments from other
members I have a question oh I'm sorry I
was just going to say go ahead chairman
Edwards just so I can understand how
you're viewing this if it has a sunset
it's a pilot
um say it for the six months or whatever
it's going to be um turns out it the
department considers it a success and
they put it on would they put it on
their prioritized requests or would it
be upon members to file legislation to
then potentially go into the budget so
so representative walner and and and wer
are better at this than
I I would I would think it could be done
in one or two ways just as you said and
two if it if it's a good program the
department the governor can come back
and ask for it as an hb2 item so either
one okay both of my options is that
right represent Wallner if if you get
involved with Federal
funding it's it's that they're not
likely to represent to recognize a
sunset because the federal funding goes
through like October you know just
that's the way the federal funds go um
if it's looking at some of the things
I'm looking at for
arpa uh Surplus they might be able to
get it in and then it would be an
automatic Sunset anyway if if the source
of funds are arpa but without knowing
the source of
funds if if we do get federal funds I
guess that's theant we don't have much
control on it some so so you yeah what
if what if the what if HHS got a 2-year
Grant after the
application you it's hard to say what
get okay
so so I can't tell exactly are you
recommending that we do a sunset or not
and based on what you said if you are
recommending a sunset then I would do a
a 30 September Sunset to coincide with
year I don't know as you need a sunset
depending on because it's going to be
ongoing they're going to be doing the
report while it's ongoing so they can
look at what's going on uh they may not
start the report you got your
mic so there's going to be a report
that's that's in the bill there got to
be a report so is this successful is it
working is it encouraging people to get
into the business um all right so you
don't start until going to be two or 3
months before you even get started now
you're going to have to look at it for
two or 3 months and and and they may not
get the report done for months after
that so it's hard to put a sunset on it
just because if you're going after
federal funds that's so difficult to
predict what what the what the grant
will
be I hear you I'm I'm still left to
think that putting a 30 September 2
25 Sunset gets us through this fiscal
year and into the next budget
cycle yeah it probably wouldn't hurt to
get the the federal fund uh Sunset date
on that question over here um yes thank
you Mr chairman um I so this there's
already Child Care scholarships for
lower for people within certain income
guidelines correct so I'm I'm trying to
trying to figure out it seems like there
may not be a huge number of childcare
workers that don't already qualify I to
me it makes more sense to go with what
representative Mooney has and then also
within that specify that we want to have
an understanding of how many child care
workers already qualify for the current
Child Care vouchers and who would then
qualify for these Child Care vouchers if
we were to expand it to everybody
working in those centers so to have this
um the the report like representative
Mooney has but specified that we want to
understand the demographic how many
people would already qualify with the
existing system and how many would then
be served by this additional system so
so if if if if if you were teed up on
this you would you would be recommending
the Mooney Amendment and not
recommending the wner amendment the
Mooney with some additional language to
say that the report shall include um an
expectation of how many are already
covered with the existing programs and
how many would be would have would
benefit from the expandion coverage I
can put that into better words but I I
would like to see that so that we can
understand as we're discussing this how
many people are actually impacted by
these additional vouchers okay and and
representative Mooney said that the
report submission should be 2025 instead
of 2024 would you would you agree with
that um with that I mean it's a matter
of just making sure we have the time
that we need in order to know what those
numbers are and uh whether we're able to
collect that I'm I'm I I I think that
representative Mooney's idea giving some
more time for the report makes sense
given all the stresses that we have but
I think that it's ABS I think it' be
really important to know how many people
this impacts
right okay I well go
ahead well I think it's going to be
difficult to know how many people it's
going to impact because I mean right now
we can I guess the department could
probably figure
out by looking through eligibilities how
many
come on up and we'll get to you how many
people are actually working in child
care who are receiving a scholarship now
they could probably give us that but
this is to attract people who aren't in
the field now into the field and
hopefully retaining some that are are
there but this is to attract people
outside to come in and I don't know that
we would be able to say that until we
so so what in this language prohibits
this the the the tuition
assistance um going to people who are
already in the
field what what what is it
that directs this to only new people it
it might it might go to people who are
already in the field so someone who is
working in the
field and um finds becomes is pregnant
has a baby they may already be there and
this is to retain them to hopefully
they'll stay in the field and not
leave at that point this is to to help
us retain our Workforce as well as to um
re get new people into it so you know
you can't it's a little hard to estimate
how many people this might bring in but
I do think that that new Futures has
done some work in trying to give it the
best estimate possible and I think that
you do have new Futures does have some
and I assume you're from new Futures I
am Michelle Meritt president new Futures
we did some preliminary analysis on this
exact issue um with the department when
we were initially working on the bill in
the Senate and so I do have some numbers
um for you that hopefully will give uh
some at least like rough estimates of
the number of people that would be
impacted by this so New Hampshire
currently has um
5,150 childcare workers who are working
um in the state of New Hampshire right
now we estimate that there around 7 to
800 of those child care workers have
children of their own and about 50% of
those would be eligible under this um
adjustment that would be made because
they are part of a two Family household
um the goal with this piece of
legislation is to deter particularly um
the worker who average right now they
make around 31 to $32,000 a year from
exiting the workforce as soon as they
have the second or um in some cases
their first child where the income
equation doesn't make sense anymore um
so we are really capturing those that
would be over the 85% of the state
median income those that are under that
um amount that 85% is about half of
those currently that have children is
what we are
estimating so the total number of folks
who would be impacted by this is around
350 to 400
families um thank
you I have a trivia question for anyone
um what is the FPL percentage
currently uh for the
efas is it 350 I want to say it's 350
it's 350 I believe 350 I think
yeah okay so so so so the 500% up to
156,000 for a family of four sounds like
a lot to me but um is there uh
representative Mooney do do you have a
not um well my thought at this point is
my Amendment 1859 H could be fleshed out
more the suggestions brought out out by
representative Lon for example would
help to do that so I'm almost wondering
if it since it needs another round
anyway to include uh the date change if
perhaps we flesh out some more
substantive information for this report
and then take it up after that
amendment's been drafted would be my
preference okay so I would propose a
subcommittee on this with representative
walner and you and representative Leon
uh to to maybe over lunch when we recess
for lunch to see if you guys the three
of you that's not a quorum could come up
with um a proposal that works for
everyone see if we see what we can agree
to agree on basically is that
yeah yes okay all right you I just
appointed did you want to be on that
sure yes okay all
right we're going to set
409 uh relative to reimbursement for
ambulance services under the State
Medicaid plan and and with this you're
picking up the clerk ship yes okay do
um I I see that representative Stringham
you may have uh something you want to
say about
409 uh sure um I I I think there was an
amendment to reduce the total
expenditure Kevin is that right that was
sent around I have an amendment for
representative Mooney that would add an
appropriation essentially for half of a
fiscal
year thank you um to to address whether
that's adequate um is um I could ask uh
Mr Litman to maybe step up I know he's
here Mr Litman come on
down did you want me to hand this
yes and with your permission Mr chair
can I well I just want to take a look at
it okay to get it fresh and then and
then I'll you can let it
rip
um uh good morning thanks for for
joining us happy to thank you um uh
before I I ask a few questions you have
anything you kind of want to say about
uh the adequacy or what you need for
this policy for this bill sure um so I
think that um the the purpose of this
bill is to address the the costs that um
ambulance companies and municipalities
that have contracts with um ambulance
companies or fire Services of
communities that um when an ambulance
goes out and makes a call and they don't
end up doing a transport there's no
reimbursement um and um what uh we don't
want to like pay for a coffee run right
but we would if someone is where they
can render a service that helps prevent
someone from having to enter an
emergency room um those are kind of
things I think we want to um incentivize
because they're good for the system when
we testified in the senate about this um
I think we're going to need uh criteria
to to approach CMS with to be able to
show that the types of things we're
willing to pay for are are services that
um are providing intervention that's
something medical not just for driving
somewhere and so um you know I think
that the
uh we need we'll need to do some work
with CMS so I think a half a year
appropriation would probably be the time
frame we would need anyways to to maybe
work through those items I also you know
in the Senate testified that um you
could May and it may still be in there
and didn't make it over from the Senate
was you could place a contingency on it
that the appropriation be contingency on
getting the state plan Amendment
approved because we shouldn't do go
forward with this if there's not going
to be a federal match um but I think in
terms of working with the appropriation
that's in here that's something we can
work with um and you know measure the
timing U to the
appropriation I that's helpful um go
ahead uh specifically um you know a lot
of ambulance services
are paid there's a there's a a billing
event or a code what they call hick piix
code for what's actually done and then
there's a separate hicp code for uh
mileage um would your and and there is a
hicp code I notice a998 ambulance
response and treatment no transport
which is currently non-billable correct
um do you think that that uh code would
be a
appropriate and how often do you think
it would be build in the state and if if
payable what would you set as the
initial rate yeah what's really hard
about this one is we have no experience
to necessarily build it off of um so I
think you know in conversation we had
offline I think you know trying to get
some experience which would help us you
know build a budget you know work with
you on the the next uh budget would be
an appropriate place to start I think
part of what codes we would use would be
uh determined by our interaction with
CMS on on the state plan Amendment this
is not a slam dunk uh in terms of U
getting an approval um so we'd have to
probably meet the conditions that that
they would feel comfortable with to make
sure it's not paying for things that
aren't providing a medical impact so
what I think I'm picking up is that
there isn't a billing code for what
we're proposing and that there may not
be approval by CMS if we direct this uh
the department to do this I think
everything except the very first point
there there is a code for for that's
non-billable today but there is a there
is a code to that okay there is a code
it's just not reimbursable correct okay
so working with CMS they could say yes
you can reimburse that and we can match
it or they may not say that right they
they they may that is very well could be
the case so they could say under these
certain conditions we would do it you
know and so I think that that's what I
think is going to happen like they may
say for you know a a cardiac condition
they may say for you know these types of
things that where they feel it's a um a
beneficial aspect for the cost and and
health of the the program so so what I'm
what I'm concluding uh is that the the
language that you've proposed
or Mooney I guess Mooney has proposed uh
that maybe we need to um include some
language that makes it this program that
we're mandating be contingent upon
receipt of federal funds Federal
approval yeah I I guess I have kind of
another thought because I'm really
concerned that um we don't we don't
understand what this could grow into
because we don't understand what the f
level will be or what the utilization
level will be um you know I was part of
the ambulance um um you know special
committee that um U uh Mr bonc Court uh
held last summer and you know uh a year
ago when we were here ambulance
companies were dropping like flies and
going out of business some of them would
been in business for for decades and um
uh that was part of the reason why we
did what we did with a budget budget
what we're talking about here is all new
money because we're not talking about
reducing the payment for any other
Ambulance Service under
Medicaid um but you know we don't I I
personally don't know whether we're
looking at thousands of service tens of
thousands of service or 100 thousands of
services I'm hearing as many as
30% of the calls that ambulances are
taking are non-billable they go there
they give somebody narom
Nar Naran they save their life and they
say you know what I'm fine and they
drive home and they get zero right and
um um so this may be helpful I I I gener
I I agree with the idea that if an
ambulance gets called out and they do
some sort of medical intervention
whether they transport somebody to a
hospital or to another Care Facility
should be kind of irrelevant because
they've taken a resource that they've
invested in out of other service and
they're doing this service I I think
just as a matter of
fairness allowing some reimbursement for
that whether I'm not talking about the
dollar amount for the reimbursement or
any of that but just as a matter of
fairness I think they ought to be able
to get some money for that and so so so
given that I I just want to make sure
that we do this in a way in which we
do this program if we get Federal money
to match with our general funds I I
don't want to create a program where
we're just doing this component with
General funds only is
what is it the the yes well how is how
is it in the contingent upon getting the
federal approval is is in the
bill right I I think the contingency
language on lines 25 through 27 of the
uh of the bill covers that all right so
that addresses my
concern so
um what you know what I'm wondering is
just getting started is how you set the
initial rate what are you going to ask
for uh are you going to ask for both
mileage and the other code is there
anything that that can be done that we
need to activate in this in this uh bill
that helps us understand what kind of
what level of utilization
that we're going to be need so we know
whether you know we're looking at you
know a million dollars of general fund
appropriation next cycle or perhaps
something substantially higher yeah uh
and and it
um this this fee doesn't necessarily
have to cover the entire cost it's all
new money for the ambulance
services so um um you know with with
that in mind that that's that's what I
don't want to miss the opportunity here
with this bill to be in a better
position to have an accurate um
appropriation next
cycle I think what will will drive that
development is looking at the the
conditions when I say conditions medical
conditions that um we would be covering
and then doing some projected
utilization estimates and working with
the the field that's out there to get
some sense of that as well um you know
to work within the budget that is
provided and then get some experience
and look at the success of the program
both um in the human context in terms of
the example you use of Naran being
administered or or in other ways in
terms of Municipal budgets and and uh
you know the ability you know the
ambulance service situation was
definitely you know the the
appropriation that was made um in hb2 I
think has made a big difference um
there's still stress out there um and I
don't want to say that that was The Cure
but I also think that know as chairman
said that I think it's fair to to
provide some compensation when you're
providing a a service of real value so
so to keep this rolling uh
representative Stringham is there based
on the me hearing your concern I just
want to know would you propose any
additional or different language to the
Mooney Amendment or are you comfortable
uh you know I just want to make sure you
have the flexibility that that you need
to
um um to be interacting with the
ambulance services providers preferably
I'd like to see them be submitting
claims as soon as possible even if they
don't pay or they pay a dollar provided
that doesn't put you in a bad spot with
negotiating the CMS
contracts and you know go ahead we've
had a good um interaction with the
ambulance providers some of the major
providers and um feel very comfortable
that you know we can engage with them to
to get some information to help inform
it better both um from a financial
standpoint but also from a CMS approval
standpoint um I I appreciate the
amendment here and I think the bill is
structured with this amendment it gives
us enough flexibility to to to get
something done that would be
useful okay um do you think they would
be able to uh submit claims that are
non-p payable or payable of a nominal
amount just so they start coming in I
think the coding language is pretty good
for what the bill defines and I know one
of our major providers in the state
sitting back here probably could comment
whether they could pay for reporting I
mean excuse me um do reporting where
there's no payment to to help us with
that but I suspect that that answer
would be yes but I want don't want to
them so would you like another witness
or are you ready to tell me if you would
change any words in this amendment
whoever that is I would like to hear
that would be great okay before he
leaves and and then I'll move on all
right because that's the bottom line we
we got an amendment if this amendment is
good it's good if if we need to change
the words then we should say that okay
thanks go ahead hi for the record Chris
day was holl Hampshire I'm a board
member of New Hampshire Ambulance
Association I'm uh also work for
American Medical
Response yeah so um uh you know in
advance of CMS uh approving anything um
how how do we get an idea of how how
extensively these codes would be used
and if you have any idea what an uh you
know a fair appropriation would be per
unit of
service um there are actually a number
of states that are either um in the
process of developing similar
legislation or have successfully passed
similar legislation in the last couple
of years uh so I would say that there
are plenty of um opportunities for New
Hampshire Medicaid to um collaborate
with other Medicaid from different
states to see what their utilization
would be I actually think and this is
just based on my experience I've been
doing this for 40 years here in New
Hampshire that the half million doll
allocation would be more than enough for
probably significantly more than
enough our goal um is not to be
reimbursed for every trip that we go on
where a transport does not occur it's
only for ones where it's medically
necessary so a a pretty significant
service would be provided um the the
Naran um example is is a great example
there are other examples such as a
cardiac arrest where typically a large
amount of um uh medications and supplies
are used and the individual may be
deceased at the scene and not
transported so there's no reimbursement
for that um and and also keep in mind
that this would only apply to Medicaid
primary Insurance patients so it
wouldn't be um anybody who's not
currently receiving Medicaid and that
narrows the scope of the indiv idual who
would be uh subject to this as
well additionally um there are
commercial insurance providers Anthem is
one in New Hampshire that already has a
reimbursement method for this this uh
particular service so they recognize
that um keeping people out of the
emergency rooms is actually a cost
savings at the end of the day and I'll
use one more example of a diabetic
person who we may respond to um they may
be hypoglycemic have low sugar we treat
them on the scene get their sugar back
to normal and then they don't need to go
to the hospital so they've saved that
that emergency room visit not only
financially but um from a personal
standpoint it's probably the last place
you want to be nowadays um and you're
getting the care that you that you um
need in the right place at the right
method and and uh you have any idea what
the commercial rates are and is it they
pay for Trans for Mileage Plus
uh the service event or just one um
there's no mileage because there's no
transport in in the states that I have
seen it successfully implemented what
they typically do is um use a either a
Medicare base rate or some type of
multiplier of that um but it's generally
you know several hundred dollar uh in in
reimbursement thank
you so so Henry you think you have you
have enough to be able to um
kind of faired out what we'd be looking
at next budget cycle I think we I think
we would and I you know in terms of um I
am familiar that there are some states
out there I haveen not had the chance to
you know interact with them I I'll
probably have a chance that once I know
what the states are um in June I'm going
to a national meeting of of the Medicaid
directors I can tap into them at that
point they're usually very generous
about sharing
information I guess I guess Mr chair my
feeling is there's nothing canect add to
the Bild either make Henry's job easier
or our job easier at next cycle um but
um you know I strongly support going
forward with it so all right uh trivia
question for you Mr Ripple uh is this
assumed to be uh lapsing this
500,000 right if it doesn't say anything
it would lapse at the end of the bium
okay so the default is that it lapses
correct yes okay and uh I I didn't catch
your name because I'm hard at hearing
but but you you just said we don't need
500,000 we need
250,000 you don't know that you said
that but that's what I heard what what
what do you really think we
need you know truthfully I'd be throwing
a dart at the board uh I think 500,000
is a good starting point but I you learn
fast yeah it's a culture change it's not
something it's not information that that
most uh providers even collect right now
I I I hear you thank you for answering a
ridiculous question um do you have a
motion yes I would like to move the
adoption of amendment number 1862 H to
Senate Bill
409 second second okay so since this is
an amendment uh show hands all those in
favor those opposed saying so no one
opposed that's what nine to nothing m
all right so so now we go on uh to we
need another motion I think of
otpa is there a motion yeah Jerry motion
representative Stringham second second
second priest um so uh Mr clerk when Mr
motion is 409 a to pass as amended with
1862 um representative
Mooney yes representative F yes
representative uh Lon
yes chairman Wier yes representative
wner yes representative tersi yes
representative Stringham yes
representative priest yes chairman
Edwards yes vote being 90 the motion
passes okay it's uh now
11:45 um I'd like to I'd like to get us
through 4:17 before we thank you so much
appreciate it um I'd like to get us
through 4:17 before we break for lunch
uh so hopefully that's the carrot
um now for 17 I should point out that
representative Hull uh had asked since
he couldn't be here today that we
postpone the final determination on the
committee position until Monday so that
he so that we could have another work
session and have him involved Mr Ripple
pointed out that as a as a matter of
procedure I could just reset us 4117 and
reschedule us to come back on
Monday problem with that is we have a
Monday afternoon with the full finance
committee and I'm I'm completely out of
the net on on the morning on a
long-standing
obligation so so it's really not
particularly feasible for me to do it
but I could ask for a replacement if I
needed um if we can get to a pretty
solid spot on
4177 I I I think I'd be comfortable just
closing it out today um and and and
explain it to representative
H um okay so 417 relative to out of home
Amendment okay do do we have the
amendment the Wilder Amendment you it
was handed out on Tuesday I do have
extra copies I believe yeah I wasn't
here
Tuesday all right and I also you need a
five minute
recess oh
okay uh so I'll bring that around I do
also have an amendment from
representative H that I think he was
hoping to have handed out today in his
okay and you're going to play the part
of Representative hole to talk about
your Amendment
yes that's what I will do um yes okay so
we'll start with representative's
Amendment from Tuesday does anyone else
representative wer are you are you
basic
21 not been charged with abuse Mike you
got your
mic thank
you where it said a parent who has not
been charged with abuse or neglect shall
be fored upon request a full Hearing in
the district of family court regarding
his or her ability to contain custom
to a parent who has not been charged
with abuse or neglect shall be deemed a
fit parent this may be challenged with a
full Hearing in the district of family
court regarding his or her ability so
that it seemed like there was an
assumption of guilt before you're even
questioned so that that was the change
and the next one
was that's a big one I agree with your
principle there innocent until proven
guilty kind of thing yeah uh who
challenges who has the authority to
challenge I guess
anybody is that is that what we want is
that anybody can challenge I mean what
would stop
um a shop operation where every one of
them gets challenged and still
accomplishes what the original original
Bill said by other means should should
we have some sort of definition you
think or or or not
about scoping who gets the challenge the
definition is there parent who's not
been charged with abuse or neglect shall
be deemed a fit parent may be challenged
yeah okay so so my my why don't you
continue and we'll come back to that all
uh uh
um
the unique needs of the child and
whether or not the parent is adequately
prepared and re re uh lettered the rest
and added on after the end of what is
here G but then in the amendment is
f the fact that a parent owns a firearm
shall not make a home unsafe which line
is that the the firearm on on it's the
last it's 26 and 27 in the amendment but
it would it would go at the end of uh
line 15 on the second
page
yep
and what is your motivation for wanting
to insert lines 12 through 27 into the
original Bill what what what what was
language go ahead represent money thank
you Mr chair as I recall the discussion
on page two of the original Bill line
three there's a line that reads the
unique needs of the child and whether or
not the parent is adequately prepared to
address those needs I believe the wer
Amendment removes that language I said
that and then moves the rest up and re
let us the rest okay and it adds the the
weapon it adds the you know the firearm
should not make a home up unsafe yeah
okay no I understand
all right uh the the division uh Vice
chair chaired the first work session
earlier this week and she recommends and
I agree with her recommendation that we
we um
uh hold off on 4177 for now uh and go
into
455 do we want to look at the other
Amendment not not just yet we're going
to hold off on 417 we're gonna we're
going to knock out 455 because Mr Litman
is here if we get done with 4555 he can
go um and I wasn't going to do 455
before breaking for lunch but now we're
we're just changing the order for the
convenience of Mr
lman good um yeah all right so so this
is all for you Mr Litman don't say we
never did anything for you all right so
uh I'm going to uh bring up uh sp sp 455
relative to Medicaid reimbursement rates
devices um just like to thank you again
hry Litman for the record uh State's
Medicaid director I think this bill
originates out of um what's happened
historically in the Dural medical
equipment environment um
back in 200 um 19 when we did the last
uh procurement of the Managed Care
Program we heard a lot from um the
smaller Dural medical equipment
providers in New Hampshire um what was
happening in the contract is uh the mcos
were able to because of the
commoditization of a lot of products
were able to drive down um reimbursement
below low um the Medicaid fee schedule
um somewhere sometimes as low as like
60% of the Medicaid fee schedule and um
to make sure that we reached all parts
of the state um we added $3 million to
the contract at that point to bring up
to create a floor of 80% of Medicaid fee
schedule for those products and the the
rationale being is that you know you can
make money easier in the urban areas and
not the the rural areas and so um I
think that um the smaller providers have
uh approached the Senate uh I think sen
Apprentice to begin with about um trying
to move that up that floor from 80% of
the Medicaid fees scheduled to 100% I
think there was a a compromise due to
all the competing priorities to look to
make some gain in this legislative
session to 90% um
and um I do think that you know in terms
of making sure that we if there is an
appropriation available that um you know
providing some additional relief to our
smaller providers and being able to make
sure we serve the whole state well is uh
a worthwhile um appropriation for the
state to
make thank you for that I I my note says
representative Stringham has something
to say and then we'll go to you
representative yes so uh the the problem
you're U that brought this bill uh to
our attention or to your Senate's
attention is that rural access because
of low Medicaid payments for things that
fall under this benefit category are too
low um and um the proposed solution is
to in increase uh this floor payment for
the entire state is that right correct
is there any um current program um
uh
for uh a higher payment in rural in
rural areas or small providers or has
that been tried before is that something
that's worth considering if not here in
the future um I I think that you know
when you talk about rural um differences
I think there's like the the far Rural
right and then there's you know you go
3040 miles outside of Manchester you get
pretty Ru sometimes too um I think
generally New Hampshire in in many in
many ways that
um there aren't there aren't significant
cost differences in in serving um uh but
when you're having to to travel to to
put this in there's I guess the the
mechanism if you were to do something
different would be to provide a
different travel allowance but I think
that ends up complicating it where do
you draw the line um I think that um you
know the the most predictable way for us
to to to move in this direction is just
to to maintain a feast schedule and not
get into you know where do you draw the
line on on travel time and and and what
have you and we do have such a
distinction in ambulances for example
yep and so they've had to had to address
that at some point
and uh one side of the street I'm sure
somewhere is one Rural and across the
street is less
R the middle group there's three and
ambulances
um uh the the list of of uh products and
and services that you sent were all with
L codes is this um um Bill limited to
things like scoliosis braces and um uh
the things that normally fall under L
codes or does it does it cover uh other
uh types of services it's it's targeted
at I think the the devices that are
applied to people
um and pain pumps um but those
are um K codes are other things too so
um I'm I'm not an expert on this part of
the the coding I worked with my team in
terms of what what it would be applied
to um I can reconfirm that if if you
feel that I need to um well I just want
to make sure the appropriation is right
for the services that we intend to we
did the appropriation that in the bill
that came over from the Senate we work
with our actuary in terms of
developing
okay thank
you okay so do do you do you think you
have an amendment you'd want to propose
based on that conversation doesn't sound
like it no this is I think you know as
long as the appropriation is correct and
that was the com Communications we've
had over the last few days um um I
support support this bill all right
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Lipman um I
have heard talk of it as a floor but the
language reads um so that the
reimbursement rate for prostetic and
orthotic devices under Medicaid so that
it is equal to 90% of the reimbursement
rate under Medicare is that the correct
language or do we need different
language for that to be a floor um you
you may raise a good point there I think
that we have the Medicaid fee schedule
and that we what we're doing here is
creating the floor um that' be no less
than 90% so I we may want to um make
that clear based on what you're you're
raising and then is a followup um I
guess on the follow-up would be to make
sure that the appropriation is still
correct um given that that's should be
that if that's intended to be a floor as
opposed to a cap I'm I'm confident that
the appropriation reflected the that we
were adding because we we approached it
the same way as when we went from no
floor to 80% so I'm I'm confident about
the appropriation component thank you
follow up yeah just as clarification
it's 90% of the Medicaid fee schedule so
at some point there I guess we were
paying 100% of the Medicaid fee
scheduled no no I think um well under
the Managed Care Program the the manag
Care organizations were using their
leverage based on National buying power
to push the rates far below the Medicaid
fee schedule um and that that's the
issue that this bill is trying to
address is to make sure that rates
aren't driven so low that you know that
where they're willing to serve is is
constrained thank
you it appears we're ready for a motion
455 yeah I I move a to
pass you need an
amendment I I didn't think there was an
amendment to this is there an amendment
to 455 there is no Amendment uh Mr
Litman has ju just suggested based on
representative Lyon's question changing
the language equal to 90% to something
like no less than 90% of the Medicaid P
schedule so you're you're wanting that
Amendment um if the uh Mr chairman if
the intention is to move the floor from
80% to 90% as opposed to having a set
rate at 90% that I think we would need
to change the language so that the
language suggests a floor because in the
fiscal note there's a mention that right
now it would cap it and that would hurt
some of the fee for service under some
of the managed agreements okay
and we didn't know how to deal with this
in policy so Mr Ripple since you're
going to create the amendment what what
do you think the amendment's going to
do well I would simply add the words no
less than on lines three and 16 so that
it reads so that it is equal to no less
than 90% of the reimbursement rate under
Medicaid Medicare I'm sorry okay does
does does everyone on division three
understand what that Amendment would
look
like is there any uh
disagreement I'm I'm is it Medic or
Medicaid that's what we're it should be
scheduled all right so so we've done
this before where we've taken votes on
amendments that we that have not yet
been drafted and then we've reserved the
right before the next during the next
next meeting to to VA validate that the
amendment comes out the way we think it
should come out we've done this
before question I'm sorry sorry I just I
want to double check with Mr Lipman um
on line four of the bill it actually
refers to Medicare and not Medicaid yeah
so the way the the current um program
works at it's 80 it's it's a floor
described with representative lay on
it's 80% of the
Medicaid fee schedule and what we're
looking to do is move that up to 90%
correct however on the bill it actually
says the reimbursement rate under
Medicare yes are we talking about
Medicare here no I think that the the
appropriation and um as we base it off
our Medicaid fee schedule um so I think
that the the proponents of this who may
have come forward may have looking for
90% of Medicare but it's it would be 90%
of our Medicaid P okay so this is just a
typo and we need to change Medicare to
Medicaid yes okay that's what I was
trying to get at no no that's that's a
good catch do you have that Mr rle I do
and I'm wondering if if it should if
it's as simple as replacing uh Medicare
with Medicaid or if it should say no
less than 90% of
the reimbursement rate under the the
Medicaid fee
schedule but I've asked Mr Litman to
write out how he believes It should read
so we'll get the uh we'll get the line
12 also refers to Medicare so that would
okay in line 17 thank
you Mr Litman the if it's okay go ahead
in the line of business Med New
Hampshire Medicaid um pricing amount
that pricing amount is based on 100% of
Medicaid right is that the table you
sent me um the the fee schedule I gave
you is the actual Medicaid fee schedules
so that's 100% of the Medicaid fee
schedule and right now the floor is
80% the Ste yeah floor is 80% of this
amount
correct you
know yes okay that's a good catch so Mr
Ripple I want to make sure everyone
understands what we think we want to do
restate I I yes I can I am waiting for
Mr Litman to provide his exact language
but we're changing the 90% to no less
than 90% And the reference to Medicare
is being changed to Medicaid although I
don't know what the exact language of
that will
be okay so there's some flexibility in
there is there anyone on the division
that is uh uncomfortable with the fact
that we're he's got to fine-tune this
representative wner
thanks I just
wondered um asking Mr Litman when the in
the Senate hearings about this did the
sponsors actually mean Medicare I I
think the the proponents may have been
looking for Medicare but I think in
terms of the the the um the fiscal note
that we prepared is you know we base it
we base it off off our own fee schedule
and that's you know that would be
implementing something completely
different and great go ahead and
Medicare rates are higher than Medicaid
rates Medicare rates are higher in fact
um there's some technical things in
terms of that when we um we have to stay
with actually below the Medicare fee
schedules on certain aspects of D
durable medical
equipment thank you represent torki did
you have
something no I was the basic question is
are you comfortable with having us craft
an amendment that we want to accept upon
validation that it was written
right I am comfortable I was just going
to point out just to make sure that on
line 12 it's not a direct cut and paste
of Medicare to Medicaid because it lists
both programs online 12 to 13 so yes I'm
sure Mr litman's language change is
going to be way more accurate than what
I could provide
okay you were all over
this so uh so go ahead representative
way on and Mr chairman the policy intent
from Health and Human Services was to
move from 80% to 90% however it's
supposed to be written for the money to
work correctly so policy-wise in the
house the intention was just to pay
increase that from 80% to 90% the right
way okay so so given that Mr Ripple is
going to create an amendment and that we
should be able to see it before the full
Finance on
Monday
um can I get a show of hands on how many
are in favor of the amendment that we've
described all right so so with that did
you have something did I stop you from
saying something the only thing I was
going to mention earlier uh in the
context of the appropriation and whether
it was sufficient is that as currently
drafted uh this is an open warrant so
it's whatever the cost ends up being uh
that amount amount is appropriated I
don't know if that's the committee's
desire or not um you could leave it that
way or you could put a specific amount
in
here do do we have a reasonable estimate
because it makes sense that we shouldn't
be writing blank checks the estimate in
the fiscal note was 620,000 in general
funds for fiscal
25 so so do we need to put an
appropriation line or something in there
if the committee were so inclined yeah
you could change the language to an
appropriation of 620,000 and I could add
the department shall be authorized to
accept and expend matching federal funds
without fiscal committee approval and
that would cover it all right so so that
feels like it just made the amendment
better all right let's do another show
of hands because it's
different all yeah any okay that was is
a a N9 nothing show of hands so we'll
look at that Friday or Monday afternoon
th thank you so much thank you um and
thank you oh no no no now we need a nopa
right okay so we need a mo is there
motion you so moved second second PRI um
House Bill
455 uh as
determined and the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment with Amendment otpa
representative
Mooney yes representative F yes
representative Leon
yes chairman Wier yes representative
walner representative tersi yes
representative Stringham yes
representative priest yes
yes Stringham and chairman Edwards yes
uh vote being nine to nothing the motion
passes all right thank thank you Mr L
thank you and I I appreciate her
accommodating just come back with pizza
or
something sounds good all right thanks
Mr chair question before lunch is this I
mean this is pretty significant
difference at what point does this um
probably not in the intent of the bill
but maybe the language at what point uh
do we need to address this with the
senate or how does well we okay I think
I understand your question if this
doesn't answer what you think your
question is let me know I I I think
we're doing a normal house function
we're taking a look at a bill we're
amending the bill we're teeing it up to
get it on the house floor the house will
vote on it and based on how the house
votes if the bills are significantly
aligned um and both passing they go to a
committee of conference and the
committee of conference negotiates uh
Within in the bright lines of the
bill you know what the house did and
what the Senate did and if there can't
be agreement within that that framework
then uh you basically the bill doesn't
pass so business as
usual I think all right I'd still like
to finish our conversation on
hungry all right all right I the the
reason I I want to knock out 417 is it
feels to me we've got another potential
subcommittee discussion around this and
and when we break for lunch we're also
kind of breaking for
subcommittees I I I I will defer to you
though would you like to break for lunch
now and
and I I'm I'm going to be sensitive and
say we're going to break for lunch now
we're going to recess Mr chair it sounds
like you like who the what you want to
have in the subcommittee why you just
have name the subcommittee I oh right
now sure if you sound like you're going
in a direction okay uh well all right so
on
417 help me summarize where we we're at
representative Mooney I think we have on
4117 we have a wer Amendment we have a
whole Amendment and then I've designated
representative Leon to channel
representative hle so uh uh and and
then um and then we would like to have
one of our blue team members on that so
who would like to talk about go
ahead I'm sorry if my comment 30 seconds
ago um jumped gun but I this is looks
like an eight page rewrite the whole
amendment that we haven't looked at
haven't had a walk through um I do
understand represent Wilder's Amendment
um but I feel like we haven't had any
more in-depth discussion to break out
into a subcommittee of two people or
three people I think is a that that's
why I was going to continue with 417 I
know maybe I just need a minute break to
go grab my water and use the ladies room
but okay so we're going to we're going
to have a f minute recess come back try
to wrap up 47
I think we're going to have a
subcommittee on 417 consisting of
Representative Wier representative Lon
and representative who who who who so Mr
chairman wait a
second would you who would want to be on
the subcommittee to talk about
417 so that when we come back we can do
something definitive well it we can't be
on two well you you can but uh right now
I thought we were repres you're not on
one are
you no okay representative priest is not
representative Stringham is not you're
on to I'm on to and I need I need to
read this in order to the channel
representative
okay um you need lunch so you can read
it so you can actually know what you're
talking about yes
okay all right so I'm going to go ahead
and Recess Recess us for lunch uh it's
12:15 I'd like to come back at uh
1:15 and uh in the meantime there'll be
a subcommittee on
404 and you're still on
two you're not not yet we haven't subc
commited 417 yet but I'm channeling
representative Hall time to yeah but
we're not we're not ready to
subcommittee that
I know I know that's why we're not going
to but then can't also be doing the sube
sub I I'm not sure how I can read this
be on the subcommittee for 352 and on
the subcommittee for 404 no we're going
to fix that so who is going to be on the
subcommittee
um we've got 352 I'd like to be on 352
please and I also have an amendment
where I would be pulling back from what
I have but adding in into the language
of what the reporting would be to have
information on what follow-up tests are
required what the cost is and who's
paying for that and how much of that
sharees of firefighters which of those
two are you more passionate about 352 or
44 352 okay so you're on that sub
subcommittee yes I I have I have an
amendment that's in drafting so I'm not
sure how much it makes sense to do that
when I don't have the link to 352 you
have an amendment on 352 yes because I'm
changing my Amendment from what it was
to something like so the subcommittee is
supposed to figure out how you guys can
agree to agree and if that Amendment
still makes sense after you Agree to
Agree then
great do that's the purp okay I'm I'm
assuming way too much all
right we are doing this a little
different because we have to complete
our work by Friday afternoon we have to
send something right so so we're
stumbling to get to the finish line and
we just we if we had more time I would
schedule another work session you know
but we're trying to figure out how to
get this all done kind of today which is
unusual
so so the purpose of the subcommittee to
me is to get three people together to
figure out what we can agree to agree on
and then take a determined Vote or
recommend Commendation on that so so
we're not finished with those bills
we're just getting you all ready to come
back and say what you would have us do
to complete those bills representative
priest yes a point of inquiry uh is
would it make sense to meet in the
morning of May the 13th prior to the
executive session is that Monday yes I I
I have pointed out that I I just cannot
be here and I I I I could delegate it
again to representative Mooney but I'd
prefer not to I one or two
others yeah so so so we thought about
that before you came into the
right so I still need somebody to be on
404 to instead of representative Lon I
guess I can do a driveby with my input
on that one but I don't know how okay
I'll I'll be on that sub subcommittee
for 404 all right okay so we're going to
break we're going to come back at
1:15 and uh hopefully by then the two
subcommittees will be able to talk about
what we've agreed to agree on
e
hey we're we're a little later than 115
but it I it feels to me like we got some
good work done um I would like to uh
pick up on all the work and conversation
while it it's still fresh in our
minds I'm going to wait for the people
with the minds to join
which when should we start with well I I
I figured 352 because I saw some
they okay Mr Ripple you
I I 352 uh was very much dependent upon
um the subcommittee working it out and
uh I'm going to wait for representative
walner and representative tersi to
re-enter the room because um the
agreements that we made were on the Fly
very verbal um and we um need to make
sure that we're hearing the same thing
so so so I'm going to hold off until U
us no it's okay we're just we're we're
yeah and poof there you
are okay representative Earth um is not
here but we can I think we can
begin so SB 35 well did did I do that I
got to use the hammer we're back out of
recess um I want to pick up with uh the
subcommittee that uh talked about SB
352 the point was to take a lot of
different perspectives and try to mold
them together and still have something
good um and maybe better so uh who who
Who's going to speak about the
subcommittee agreement on what we'd like
to
do thank you Mr chair so for the
purposes of the discussion I am going to
move a motion for the adoption of
amendment number
1869 to Senate Bell
552 excuse me
352 and I will speak to that
Amendment go ahead a second oh second
second thank you okay as was originally
introduced the
morning this
amendment would enhance the language of
Senate Bill
352 and clarifying that it's any
combination of one or more of the
following tests a blood test and
ultrasound of vital organs Etc as
opposed to uh reading in the original
version as though all the tests are
required so that is the consensus of the
subcommittee and also representative
tersi who had a previous amendment that
I don't believe is going to be
introducing because of this amendment so
I would ask the members to vote
Yes does does that summarize the
totality of the subcommittee agreements
or because I I'd kind of like to see
where we're going okay no it doesn't
because representative Lon has a
amendment that addresses a separate
section of the bill the reporting
section and I'm sure she'd want to speak
to that representa Leon you love to
speak to this yes I speak too much um
thank you very much for this opportunity
um I I raise these concerns because
quite frankly I have these concerns but
they don't seem to be shared and I'm not
going to stand in the way of having an
opportunity to have the test that is
required or that is desired so I am
withdrawing my previous Amendment but I
do want to make sure that we know what
follow-up testing comes from these who
pays for them and how much the
firefighters need to pay so I have
Amendment that's in drafting oh it's
printing right now so that's even better
um so I don't know if you I'll tell you
what it is and then we can read it um it
adds in section seven it already has the
findings to include the number of
firefighters screened test conducted
results of tests then the amendment adds
follow-up testing to confirm the results
of the screening cost of follow-up tests
and method of payment including the
firefighter share of costs and then back
to the existing language Trends and any
recommendations for the pilot program um
I think my concerns about how it's paid
for are founded and I may be wrong this
will give us the information about
whether or not we need to be concerned
about the out of outof pocket costs or
if my concerns were not based in reality
I think that we should have this in the
the report and I think that it'll be
helpful as we proceed forward so those
um since it's not it's bolded in mine
but not yours that starts halfway
through line six and goes through most
seven all right so so my objective on
this is uh in order to keep this simple
for our colleagues in the house and on
the finance committee rather than having
two amendments on this bill I'd like to
uh merge them does anyone see any issue
with creating another amendment that
just collapses these two onto one
document
sorry can I just get quick clarification
on the number wait wait yeah go ahead
what's your question did I just get a
quick clarification on the number of the
first amendment that was offered
I have an 1869 I just want to make sure
that's the one that's being discussed it
be
yes that's our base on yes your that
okay
so so I'm not hearing any concern about
a conflict if we
merged uh the the Mooney Amendment 1869
with the new Layon Amendment 1894
there's no concern about merging them
the reason I advocate merger is because
uh the people have to follow our work
and the finance committee later has to
approve an amendment the house has to
approve an amendment so I'd like to just
get this down into one
Amendment representative Mooney would
would you be willing to reconsider your
motion yes I'll reconsider my motion uh
at the suggestion of the chair I also
want to add too that my Amendment takes
out the skin cancer provision and
removes the cap thank you I withdraw my
motion okay so we we could use another
motion that would um allow us to merge
uh 1894 and 1869 into a new document do
you see any problem with that Mr
Ripple I don't uh no and I think you I
think you could vote on that motion now
rather than waiting for the combined
Amendment right right representative
priest I second the motion is made by
representative Mooney to combine to
merge these two amendments together in
one piece um because I think your
arguments are correct it would make it
much clearer and simple thank you all
right so representative tki I can I can
see it say it I just feel like here they
are let's do it let's be done move them
along okay we're really close to that
though really
close Okay so so we have a a motion and
a second to merge
1894 and 1869 into one amendment to 352
and that that'll be drafted and if it uh
is okay we're going to have a chance to
look at it next week to make sure that
we're okay um that then then we're fine
so um because we're talking about
amendments can we do a show of
hands show a hands in favor of merging
the two amendments okay no one's opposed
so so let's take that route that path
otpa yeah okay moved
seconded um is there any further
debate okay with seeing no further
debate uh go ahead representative Mooney
thank you I'll talk in favor of the
motion o PPA uh just to summarize where
we are there will be a combined
Amendment drafted one Amendment it will
include my Amendment with the language
as well as removal of skin cancer as
well as removal of a cap as well as some
specific language on the reporting piece
that's been Pro offered by
representative Lon this is very
important we certainly appreciate our
firefighters in New Hampshire in our
community
and it's very important that this pass
and I want to thank all of you that
worked on this and those in the
subcommittee that worked on this because
consensus was built built relatively
quickly and that's uh to the credit of
the people that serve obviously everyone
has an eagerness to serve you thank you
very
much so Mr clerk when you're ready to
take a Mr chairman could I say something
before we're done to representative Leon
um thank thank you um and I want to also
thank everybody for coming for a good
agree good agreement my intention
throughout all of this was to make sure
that we had the most useful most
beneficial test that would have minimal
harms to our firefighters because they
do so much for us um I'm thankful that
we'll be able to better understand what
cost they have to bear as part of this
testing because quite frankly they and
their families bear a cost that none of
us can imagine between everything they
do to protect us and everything that
they have to do as they raise their
families and take care of them with all
of the challenges they face not just
cancer and everything else so I just
want you all to know that all of my
concerns were to make sure that we had
the best possible test to have the best
possible health and lifespan for all of
families comment would you like to talk
about how great firefighters are too I I
do but I also want to say uh you know
second what was just said but also say
that uh uh there really hasn't been the
kind of effort to do uh a full cancer
screening for any atrisk
population uh I think the results of of
what happens here um you know uh May
draw a lot of national attention not
just for firefighters but for all of
America and that face different kind of
risks so um I'm happily happily going to
support
this and and I'm looking looking forward
to my next family reunion my
brother-in-law is a firefighter so go
representative Earth I going backwards I
think it would be better if somebody
else made this motion because I really
not going to be able to speak to it very
competently in front of the finance
committee and there's obviously much
bigger experts here like repres sentive
tki are you I I think it's okay we have
a motion on the floor I'll withdraw my
motion okay and suggested better person
somebody else motion to otpa I'd be
happy to make the motion oh go ahead
what's your motion I would like to make
a motion to division three that we
accept House Bill 352 with the potential
pending Amendment uh both the Mooney
Amendment and the Layon amendment that
has the addition of additional lay on
reporting and removes the cap and the
skin cancer
second okay motion seconded Mr clerk
when you're ready to take a
vote House Bill 350 two ought to pass as
amended representative Mooney yes
representative F yes representative
leyon yes uh chairman Wier yes
representative walner yes representative
tersi yes representative Stringham says
yes representative priest yes and
chairman Edwards yes and I would just
ask the question uh who among us is
going to begin preparing the uh
committee report the blurb for this B
bill you made the motion I would be
happy to I have until Tuesday I believe
oh yeah you got lots of time I just I
wanted to give you a heads
up okay um all right so that was real I
I think really fine subcommittee work
thank you so now let's drop down
to um 404 while that's still fresh in
our minds relative to expanding the
child care professions eligibility for
the child care
scholarship thank you gentlemen and any
you um so so who would like to speak on
404 I'd be glad to thank
you so we um the subcommittee came
together and we talked about some
changes that we would make to my
original Amendment and the first one was
um on line four of the original
amendment that I brought in this morning
was we would use median income 100% of
median income instead of the 500% of the
federal poverty and median income is um
lower than the uh
500% um we had a lot of fun talking
about whether this was a pilot program
or not and we decided this is a project
so um throughout the bill you'll see a
new a new word that it it becomes a
child care Workforce
project um and then um at the end of the
bill as you remember there was a section
that talks about the funding being
non-aps and we did um change it to LA
the the funds will lapse at the end of
the
bium and representative money also was
working on an amendment which she can
probably explain better than I can about
reporting about the um Department
developing a report and we incorporated
her Amendment about the report and some
specific items she has um the report um
gathering information on and we'll
incorporate that into the 404
Amendment any any I'm open to questions
let's have representative Mooney and
then we'll do questions can I do one
thing we did engage uh representative uh
Ross Barry in this discussion because it
did come from the special child care
commun um committee so we did engage him
in the conversation about the changes
that we were making
thank you representative
Mooney thank you Mr chair I'll start
with the reporting piece of it uh it was
mentioned earlier that the reporting
piece in my Amendment and in the bill
proposed here in the house was not
really fully fleshed out and complete so
we added a few questions and topics to
the reporting piece that could be
included so they would be how many
qualif for the project how many may be
added to the project what it upgrades
would be needed and the suggested
funding and of course a catchall uh of
what else could be included in this
report based on this project also the
date of the report would be due as I
2025 I was going to put this report in
as a separate catchall Amendment like I
did earlier today uh to replace the
entire bill but I'm not going to
introduce that Amendment I'm going to uh
instead back the walner amendment and
would like to briefly touch upon one
piece of the walner amendment that uh we
discussed there at the tail
end in addition to everything
representative walner
to the waiver request so that's on page
two of the house version line 32
starting there in that paragraph we will
add that federal funds are to be used
for the
project if they can't be found or
obtained then it would revert to State
funds so that too will be a piece in the
walner amendment that I intend to vote
for on Senate Bill 404 thank you Mr
chair to to make sure I'm clear what
what what's we're doing is we're taking
what representative walner and you have
said and we're giving it to Mr Ripple to
create a new Amendment a fresh Amendment
that's got everything in it
right one Amendment right so because Mr
Ripple is critical I mean we've just
been talking what's important is Mr
Ripple understands this enough to be
confident that we can create an
amendment that takes care of these
complexities do you want to maybe
summarize what you think or just tell us
uh bottom line comfortable before he
does there there one other piece the I
think section three should be removed
then
correct or some clarity should be put in
there as
well on the top of Page
Three where the more the appropriation
is
happening so I think the I think the
idea behind representative walner
amendment was that it would keep the
amounts in her earlier Amendment from
today of $1 million for the program and
implementation yes rep representative
Leon um thank you Mr chairman um I just
want to make sure sure that I'm clear on
this are we saying that that if federal
funds aren't granted we're not going to
fund it or if federal funds aren't
granted we're not going to pay for it
from the state let me tell you what I
think I heard okay uh that way I can
check to see if I heard right we're
going to ask first to spend Federal mon
money if we cannot get the federal money
then we're willing to do this project
using State money General
funds is that right correct I didn't
okay I I thought we were going to say
that it was Federal only because it
would be pretty hard to imagine that
unless uh we require it to be federal
funds that they might might decide not
to fund it if we'll backfill it at the
state level but that was my
misunderstanding I apologize no you're
fine uh that and that's a valid issue so
issue that we talked about with chairman
Barry uh and chairman Barry's
perspective if I heard it right is that
he's absolutely convinced the federal
money money will be coming and represent
walner he is convinced that it'll be
coming
um
but I'm not good at counting my chickens
before they hatch and and my
understanding was that chairman Barry
believed that so long as we were not
willing to spend State funds there was
no way the F federal government would
turn us down but if we were willing to
spend State funds they may I I think I
I mean you got to put some skin in the
game to get them to say okay and I I I
think the position is we we'll show that
we willing to put skin in the game and
the expectation is they're probably
going to deliver on the federal money
representative wner thank you I think
you said it correctly thank you
okay all right so representative Mooney
thank you just want to go back to
representative F's comment about
Appropriations that is changed in the
walner amendment as it was previously
this morning thank
you representative priest uh thank you
Mr chairman uh I have a question to
representative Mooney she mentioned four
qualifying questions in the reporting I
have three could could she repeat those
again yes absolutely thank you
representative for the question so in
that reporting Clause would
appear how many qualify for the project
mhm how many may be added to the
project what it upgrades may be
required and suggested funding going
forward and then of course the catchall
of any other topic and concern to be
included in the
report thank you as well as a date
okay so at a high level if you were just
to say you were certain that you got all
of this or if you want to like drive
into detail so that we know exactly what
we're going to vote on um I'll go into
detail especially on the bit about
prioritizing federal funds because I've
already sent this to OS but just to make
sure that what I've sent them is
accurate I'll I'll repeat it here
so the the new Amendment would be based
off of Representative wahner's earlier
Amendment however it would remove the
non-aps provision that's in the bill now
and is in that Amendment so the funds
would lapse it would be called a project
um and it would have a six-month
duration from January 1st to June 30th
2025 and as an aside I think it'll
probably be taken out of Statute as it's
in the bill now and placed into chapter
law only by OSS since it's a temporary
program now
essentially the
threshold for eligibility rather than
500% of the federal poverty level will
income the reporting requirement will
include the items that representative
Mooney just mentioned uh so an uh an
estimate of how many people qualify for
the existing Child Care scholarship how
many will be added as a result of the
project any needed technology or other
upgrad grades a suggested funding level
going forward and any other relevant
information and that report will be due
November 1st
2025 as far as prioritizing federal
funds my understanding was that that
should go into section two of the bill
which deals with the waiver request but
I would like some input from the
committee on whether they think it
would best fit in section
are you prepared to answer the question
representative
Mooney I myself don't see a problem with
that in terms of placement based on the
amendment we just verbally went over
regarding that
section I don't know if others uh
disagree but I myself don't see a
so is it the committee's intent that I
would replace the appropriation language
like Federal fund shall be used first
where where available with General funds
remainder representative
walner yes but then I think you would
need to have wouldn't we need to have at
that point an appropriation that would
be available if they are will still need
the dollar amount right so I so there
have been other bills um that make an
appropriation of federal funds first uh
with General funds used for the
remainder so I guess my question is is
that how you want to treat the two
appropriations of $1 million and
100,000 so if there are no federal funds
it would be General funds right okay up
to if there are no federal funds it
would be allowed up to to a million
dollar okay of of state general funds
okay I mean you know it's possible that
the feds could come back and have a
50-50
program we don't know
yet okay so I'll have it drafted that
way are are you complete on your summary
yes all right are there questions about
what Mr Ripple just laid out are you
prepared to vote on that amendment to be
drafted and if if it is in line with
what we just described then we're good
and we're recommending it to the full
finance committee if we if any one of
you looks at it and goes this is not
what we agreed to then I don't know what
we're going to do we we we won't go
forward it'll create chaos but that can
happen so um all right any questions if
not um show of hands how many uh are in
favor of the amendment as
described all right uh any opposed not
seeing any opposed n
nothing and and then uh we need a a
otpa representative
walner I move ought to pass is amended
on um House Bill
second second second
Toki or Mooney let's do Mooney looks
bipartisan
um all right so Mr clerk when you
understand the motion take a vote this
is on House Bill 404 as amended uh with
a 2B determined
Amendment
um uh forwarded by representative walner
and seconded by money representative
Mooney yes representative F yes
representative Leon yes uh chairman Wier
yes uh representative walner yes
representative tersi yes string of votes
yes representative priest yes chairman
Edwards yes vote is nine nothing the
motion ought to pass as amended passes
thank you Mr clerk okay because my note
taking has been horrible would somebody
tell me what we did with SB 355 the
[Music]
CMV I know that's why I said tell me
what we did so Mr chair yeah 355 was
amended with my proposed amendment that
would put back in general education on
the subject and include an opt out
provision it passed ought to pass with
Amendment 7 to zero I'll be glad to
write the committee report thank you
okay um so
404 um who will Who is lined up to write
that report
rep I think it should be yes
representative walner has just
volunteered
tersi okay so again uh I just need to be
reminded what we've already done on 409
the ambulance
you adopted it with uh an amendment that
I've yet to have drafted to change
Medicare to Medicaid the schedule in
various instances and make a few other
changes as well all right now and who
will write that blur I'll do that as
well as an
appropriation that's
right okay so and then on
4555 we accepted that 9 nothing was
there was there amendment to that or was
that as
is yeah there's uh there's still a
question mark on the amendment on the
amendment number when we voted on it
right Mr chair that was the bill where
representative tarki pointed out the
numerous references to Medicare not
Medicaid and so that amendment was uh
verbally adopted though we've not seen
it yet in writing for 455 I thought that
was the ambulance discussion no that was
that was the orthopedic okay so so we've
got an
otpa on
455 and who who would want to write that
um I can do that one too you'll do that
one
okay string them I will say I sent I did
send a follow-up note after comparing
Medicare rates to the Medicaid table he
sent so they weren't that directly
correlative so some are higher and some
are lower so I asked him to check his
numbers
okay so we still have five to go uh I
think two of them are really quick but
let's let's go back to 417 we opened uh
the door on
lunch um we had representative Wier
talk about his
Amendment and then I asked
representative Lon to channel
representative hle and before we get
into this I'm going to end up recessing
this uh after we talk about it a little
bit to Tuesday
Morning um that's when representative H
will be here I'll be here it's going to
be before the the the the finance no you
cannot no I had a conversation with
chairman wer earlier this week that
Tuesday morning I have um a longstanding
appointment and which is why it was
scheduled at 1: p.m. so
if we continue as you just stated we
would not be able to get me a sub if I
was supposed to come back for 1 p.m. you
we can't get a sub for you for Tuesday
morning no because if I'm coming at 1:00
I can't par you got to be off campus all
day oh I see well I can't be here either
so that'll balance things out
you can't you can't have us up I'm we
can't be here in the afternoon we'll
both be here in the afternoon yes right
so so representative walner i' i' i' I'd
like to be able to recess us to Tuesday
Morning knowing that representative
tersi and representative Earth will both
session are we going to discuss sorry I
didn't mean to
I'm just curious are we going to like
walk away from this right now or are we
going to have a discussion right now I I
think we're going to listen to
representative um um Leon who has
prepared to talk to the whole Amendment
uh and and I think the point of it will
talk just enough for us to be able to
come back Tuesday
Morning uh and then really do the vote
on Tuesday morning I guess I have some
concerns about that since you're
accommodating representative H who can't
be here but yet I can't be there and I
might have some comments on
um are you not able to share your
comments before Tuesday morning no I can
but you just said we'd listen to
representative Lon and then move on to
Tuesday morning and I didn't know if
we'd have a discussion representative
Hull had made a prior
request
Tuesday I just feel like we if we're
going to have a discussion on this bill
and and representative H's Amendment
then we need to bring into the
discussion of chairman wier's Amendment
and what some concerns might be we we we
did introduce the Wilder Amendment we
haven't discussed it not yet I'm trying
to get all the Amendments out so that we
see the terrain that we're going to walk
I'm sorry if I misunderstood but it
sounded like we were not going to have
the in the discussion until Tuesday I
apologize no we're going to have a
little bit of discussion we're going to
introduce the Amendments we're going to
walk through them a little bit so that
we fertilize our brains about it and and
uh wait till uh Tuesday to make a
recommendation of division three to uh
ahead so I think what we're trying to do
is we're trying to accommodate uh
representative Hall who is not here but
who
has a very
expansive Amendment
yes we have to go back we have to be
here on uh Tuesday afternoon for full
full Finance to do the executing we have
one I I just guess I don't understand
how we're going to actually be able to
go through this
whole amendment that he's brought
in you know how involved discussion
gets and then have something ready to
1:00 it feels like what we need need to
do is just what we've done on some of
these other bills we have developed the
amendment that we've all agreed to and
then we'll take we'll take a look at it
when we get here on Tuesday or
Monday and say yes this is what we
agreed to I just think waiting and then
going through this huge amendment that
day is going to be very
difficult and there's also 10 bills to
go through in that
afternoon yeah
so okay so never make a decision that
doesn't need to be made yet so I'm not
going to make a decision we're just
going to plow through this and see where
it takes
US Representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I was just going to let you
know that I do have some better
highlights of where the changes are so
that I'll be able to walk people through
and they are some pretty much
consistent consistent language changes
throughout so that if determining that
certain wording is correct as it flows
through the bill it's not as big of a
change as it does appear but it's
important good so it's not going to be
hard to understand the amendment then
I'm not going to assume that anything's
easy to understand but I think it's a
lot less daunting than I thought before
we broke for lunch okay you're you're up
tell us what you want us to
know so so what I've asked
representative Leon to do is to take the
whole Amendment as though she was
channeling representative ho so that we
can get the best case for it and then we
can probably discuss it some so she's
not advocating her position she's
representing representative whole
go ahead okay thank you Mr chairman um
looking at the amendment moving in
section one um if you look on line 8 it
adds the language that there's no
options for instate placement that exist
um by having no options for instate
placement that exists then there's that
prioritization for instate um and then
the other language that's different in
there is that lines 13 and 14 it would
require both the written approval of the
director of dcyf and increased judicial
oversight The increased judicial
oversight is already there so so in
addition to the the director of DCF who
gets added as a sign off no the director
of DCF is the one who is
added okay there's already in the ex in
the bill as we have it I believe already
includes the increased judicial
oversight um I I would assume that
having the director of dcyf um sign off
means that we have specific
accountability so that there's an
individual who was involved in the
decision that 1573 which was basically
the house okay all right back up to page
still on page one line
four it had least restrictive crossed
out and less restrictive put in he's
gone back to least restrictive I don't
see that line four I I I read as read as
follows what page are you on so first
yeah original Bill
oh
okay that's basically what he's changing
is the original Bill 15 15 different
places to least restrictive instead of
less restrictive yep okay um that one
that one I I guess I I I missed that one
that I guess that's in the tra changes
so that's an important one to figure out
policy-wise if less restrictive or least
restrictive is more important so so how
do you see that represent wer what what
do you see the tradeoff is between those
two
conditions least restrictive versus
language as opposed to the bill CH less
broad it's obvious which is the least
restrictive there could be 10 of them
that were less
restrictive so least restrictive is more
specific than less restrictive right
would you prefer less the least
well here's he he's emphasizing least
restrictive on on what page on what line
item of his amendment is is the least
page six on his Amendment line six line
six line
six and it's on it's line four oh there
it is how come that's not shown up as a
bold least restrictive because it's
going back to the current law as opposed
to what's in the bill um and I apologize
for missing that no no I'm I'm totally
missing it so so that's great thank you
Mr all right I I interrupt go ahead
representative
walner um someone from the child
advocate office is here who could
probably help us get through some of
this we'll we'll Reserve that but right
now we're still just at the very outset
amendment
yeah so so I'm I'm I'm sorry I I want to
your representative Lon describe the
amendment and then we'll bring you up
and uh allow you uh to comment
[Music]
and th th this work session is
predominantly for the division 3
discussions not for more input but we'll
we'll we'll get your input when it's
appropriate yes I was I just thought
since um she had worked with
representive H and talked to him that
represent Lon who got handed this
amendment um an hour ago I hear your
point thank you yes and um
sorry go ahead sorry I didn't mean to
jump in um so as we go through if we
mark it up we know where those changes
are the next one if you move down to
line 29 um it is using the clear and
convincing evidence which is the higher
standard and one that is already used in
many areas there's the concern that
going to preponderance of evidence um
would be lowering the bar and then the
courts would need to decide if Our
intention legislatively is to lower the
bar from the current clear and
convincing um language all right um then
moving to page two there was something
else in that section though that was
added I
just on line
25 line 25 of the
amendment oh the deemed a fit
parent I I see the same Lang let me see
here that's the same language it
represent the wer brought out right it's
in the wer minut sorry I don't have the
wer one direct clean from me apolog yeah
no no that's just a that's just a
replicant of of Wier sorry yes that's
the same as Wier otherwise the changes
the similari is and
difference so that has the same language
as the Wilder amendment in line 25 uh
moving to page two line five instead of
having the unique needs it adds the
words the unique physical mental
emotional and medical needs because that
is how it was described and by having
that it spelled out it is more clear um
so instead of deleting that section it
clarifies it then moving to um section g
which is lines 12 through
17 that um has the language um that has
the language within this where um
Senator bsel had added the parent
parents cooperation but instead of being
a stick it turns it into a carrot where
their effort to provide any records
necessary shall be weighed as a factor
in favor of the fitness of the parent um
so that instead of it being Mark against
the parent for not cooperating it is a
mark in favor of the parent um and then
additionally this has the Wilder
language about the fact that a parent
owns a firearm shall not make an home in
safe adding the words nor be waited
against the
parent then um moving to so so that's
more words that's more words nor be
waited against the parent correct
okay moving to line 27 um it has the
contrary to the welfare it says that if
the remaining in the care of the child's
parent or legal guardian is determined
to be contrary to the welfare of the
child which is that higher standard that
we currently have that is current New
Hampshire law so if we passed it with
weaker language um that would give conf
give uh M the judges would need to know
whether legislatively we're trying to
weaken the protection for the families
um and for the families staying together
what line were you on I'm sorry that is
on line 27 contrary to the welfare of
the child on page two on page
two wait a
second yeah so we're going to do this so
we minimize confusion so 26 and 27 reads
if remaining in the care of the parents
child's parent or legal guardian is
determined to be contrary to the welfare
of the child to secure
placement and the bill as it reads reads
if presume that remaining in the family
home is in the best interest of the
child but if it is determined to not be
in the child's best interest that is
weaker language um for the protection of
keeping the family together um when it's
appropriate than having the language
that if remaining in the care of the
child's parent or legal guardian is
determined to be contrary to the welfare
of the
child all right then on line 28 it adds
the link as defined in RSA 170-25
um only kin is defined so this is one of
the areas that I had noted but I didn't
join with him on drafting this language
kin is defined in RSA
170-25 fictive kin is not so if we're
intending to prioritize blood related
kin um that is a subset of the
definition in the statutes so if it's
with kin or fictive kin if they're
decide if they should be viewed the same
then that should say with kin as defined
in ours so um we would want to change
that in his amendment to strike out oric
of kin because that definition does not
exist if there should be a distinction
between blood kin and general kin then
we would need to note that and make that
in a way that's not inconsistent with
our other definition of kin so the
policy committee had been trying to get
the definition of fictive kin into
something was it was it 1573 or was it
417 it was in 498
um 498 is a bill was a bill that used
the term fictive kin they were told in
policy committee that there was a
definition in RSA
170-25 but that definition isn't for
fictive kin that definition is for kin
okay so so it seems to me like our
statute still wants a definition of
fictive kin if you're going to use it if
we use the term kin and if we want to if
there are times when we want to refer to
blood kin uh so those people who are
related by blood as opposed to the
broader definition that we use in our
statutes which is essentially fictive
kin I think it's um in order to access
tanif that we need to have the
definition of kin be broader to include
fictive kin I believe that's why it was
expanded last year as kin instead of
naming it fictive kin and yes I have the
same headache about this as you do
representative about the challenges of
the de details yeah I guess I get I
what's and I'm not an expert on this so
I apologize what is concerning me is the
way you use the term blood kin versus
kin because I think we all know that we
have family that's not related by blood
um so I'm just getting weary in a policy
area that we're not versed in that was
the headache look do do you see in
general the value not getting into the
specifics but do you see in general the
value of having definitions for two
terms Ken and fictive Ken and then if
you do then it's just an issue of
compatible I guess as I'm looking back
at the original Bill
though I mean in my head I can use an
layman's terms what that means kin INF
fictive kin I understand as we've heard
it you know in testimony from the
Department from talking to people in
children family law I guess I'm
questioning if we need to dig in here
and give it more
definition as opposed to what the
testimony was from
OCA in in you know the the way they use
department and thank you when you look
at this um we've been told that the
definition of the word kin includes
what's colloquially known as fictive kin
so using both the terms kin and then
fictive kin given that our statutes
Define kin as the colloquial fictive kin
we're talking about fictive kin or
fictive fictive kin when we say kin or
fictive
kin that is a lot of why I was trying to
get to a definition in 498 so that we
could have it correct but um I had
expected the amendment on 417 to pass
with that definition um that the child
and family law committee had had so
there was no addition of the definition
of fictif kin to
498 to representative Mooney thank you
very much so I am on the
DHHS website of the State of New
Hampshire where there is a whole page
entitled
kinship care in that on that page
there's a Definition of kinship and it
says Point Blank if you are a family
friend have a close relationship or are
an important person in the life of the
child or teen then you are considered
quote fictive King is it possible to
include this website language from our
I'm pulling up the definition in
170-25 right
175-25 there is only kin defined and kin
is sorry they're not alphabetical which
makes it extra fun it is item eight kin
meets a child or children for who there
for who for kin means a child or
children who for for which there is a
connection or history between a child or
their parents and another responsible
adult including but not limited to
related adults so that's our definition
of kin which is the colloquial
definition of fictive
kin um to me the F the related adults
idea of kin which is the one that you
think of is I that I'm been referring to
as blood kin the question is if we need
a if if we're going to have kin and
fictive kin within our law we need to
understand what that difference is
because otherwise this is going to lead
to a lot of confusion if we simply say
with kin as defined in RSA
170-25 that includes that broader one as
on the website so it seems like the path
of least resistance to me is on line 28
of the whole Amendment striking the the
three words or fictive
Ken right y yes okay I I'd rather do
that and that way we're getting out of
the Poli issue and getting back to the
other issues yes and um and also if I
may make a suggestion perhaps adding to
this bill um if assuming it's Germain to
amend that definition to say kin or
fictive kin since we mean that as the
same definition because fictive kin is
used elsewhere in our statutes now that
will be so I'm trying to I'm trying to
duck it you know that's a policy debate
that the policy committee can have how
to fix our law with Ken and infective k
i I don't want to do that understood
that it's a it's a peeve of mine but I
will pass on that because I'm a GU here
it's it's valid you're valid if we're
going to use the word or fictive kin we
need to have two definitions we we'll
fix it in this bill and we'll leave it
to them to fix the rest all right okay
what else
next moving to page three lines 15
through 21 section
B this is filling in the stat statutory
guidance um because right now there's
silence around what happens when the the
needs of the child cannot be met by can
fictive kin or in a foster family home
um because right now there's no guidance
to the courts about what would happen if
the ideal selection within the whole
category of prioritization is not
available um and it would be beneficial
to the courts to have that guidance and
stating also that neither the shortage
or lack of foster family homes nor the
lack of community- based resources as
expressed by the department um that's an
important phrase shall be acceptable
reasons for determining that the needs
of the child cannot be met in a family
setting nonetheless if there's no can
fictive can or lied foser home available
at the time that the court is ordering
placement of the child the court May
order the best available temporary
placement while the Department of Health
and Human Services prioritizes locating
a preferred placement so so I like this
language better than what we had in 1573
but online if we were to take whole
completely uh uh then fictive K on line
15 would have to be struck and on line
19 fictive Ken would need to be struck
okay correct all
right but okay why wouldn't you do that
go ahead thank you Mr chair I the the
term fictive kin makes it very clear
that there's a non-blood
relationship I see this uh definition on
the dhh website this term has carried in
all of these versions of this bill and I
I find it to be rather critical that it
be either left in and defined or or left
in and leave it to uh somebody to search
the dhh website for the definition but
my recommendation is leave it in uh as
it's uh critically important that there
be a distinction between a blood kin and
a non-blood
relative so my issue with your
observation is is that the law currently
describes Ken broadly enough to include
the definition of fictive Ken so so we
referenced the definition of Ken by
Statute reference right what line was
that where we referenced Ken by Statute
that was on page two line 28 line 28
okay so so representative Mooney I would
I would posit that because we're we
would change that to say with a kin as
defined by RSA blah then everywhere we
use kin in here you would refer back to
the de definition and as we heard it's
broad enough to capture fictive kin my
issue with keeping kin and fictive kin
is that it implies that in the statute
we have def def differential or
differential definitions which we do not
so so I would just keep it all kin to be
consistent with the statutory reference
does that make sense yes I'm going to
look at that I'm going to look I'm going
to look up that RSA right now but
understood your point yes okay and and
and again I I do think we'll probably
recess on this and come back Tuesday is
my my instinct on it so we don't have to
decide this right
now right no this is just we're just
going through the weeds here so
representatively on what else um now on
page three moving down to lines 32 and
33 it adds the words unless the
department demonstrates evidence to the
um to the
contrary so this is about the return of
custody as in the best interest of the
child and with showing that the parent
has an ability to provide proper
parental care it shall be presumed that
return of the C return of custody is in
the child's best interest unless the
department demonstrates evidence to the
contrary so that gives that opportunity
where um the department can step in in
order to protect that child if they need
right then moving to page four line
three it adds that um in order to order
a not aate placement there needs to be
the express written finding that no
instate options exist and that out of
State placement offers specialized
programming and services that are unable
to be provided within New Hampshire um
maybe a little bit belt in suspenders
with that and the unable to be provided
in New Hampshire but given that we do
want to keep our kids here in New
Hampshire when we can I think that seems
reasonable okay um then if you move to
line 8 through n it adds the written
approval of the director of DCF in
addition to the increased judicial
oversight so that's a recurring theme
um now moving time out so we're
referring to increased judicial
oversight so there's a part of the
amendment or part of the underlying bill
because 1573 didn't talk about
additional judicial oversight so so
where are we in 417 or this amendment
that talks about when when we say and
judicial oversight that's already in the
original it's in the original yeah all
right what's been added is the written
okay so the written approval I can see a
signature on a document by the dcyf
director I'm not certain who the
signatory authority is to to represent
increased judicial
oversight so um if you look at the
language I would read both and you have
the written approval of the director of
the DCF
and then separate is increased judicial
oversight so the problem is it's
connected with an and it's it starts
with a written approval and then
connects two different entities with an
and one of them is determinable the
director the other one is not I mean I I
don't know who is accountable for the
increased judicial oversight to sign
something bottom of page three in the
original okay so it's I don't think the
oversight is a matter of signing a
document and if you want to clarify that
then we'd probably want to break this
more into list form by being able to
break out one or two I guess it would be
a and b however you would do that I I
think I would just delete and judicial
oversight increase judicial oversight
because we're talking the the word the
term is written
approval what
what's
yeah I I don't see a signature there
finding a written
finding this I think the signature is
only intended for the director of DCF
not a signature for the judicial
oversight I think that's a policy where
they would need to have the policy of
the oversight and specifically requiring
the signature so since that's a
recurring theme that's probably
something we should put a pin in and
look at as one of those policy decision
one of those decisions that would flow
throughout this entire section and
throughout the entire Bill okay so so
who track my thinking am I am I just
wrong here yeah leave it the way he's
got it just leave it the way he said it
okay yeah all right so it's clear enough
go ahead okay now if you move down to
line 14 we again um do contrary to the
welfare of the
child I
believe and I apologize I have to find
where I am in here because I I touched
it and I left the page so now I need to
get to
correct oh yes I have my uh track
document where I lost
myself thank goodness I'm used to 40
page bills so I can find myself again
[Music]
okay okay there we go I've got that now
is six in B so we're going to move to
page
department so online three it adds as
expressed by the department about the
shortage of lack or Foster F La shortage
or lack of faser foster family homes nor
the lack of Community Based resources as
expressed by the department shall be
acceptable reasons for determinating
that the needs can't be in the family
setting that gives accountability about
who makes that decision that's one that
that follow that flows through this in
several areas can you refers back to the
original bill on where we're at I'm
trying like trying to do a side by side
and I'm I'm trying to do it real time as
well I will find it I got it page
four you'll see the section B on line 28
on the original Bill page
four and there's lots of language added
there
nonetheless and that's giving that
flexibility and the direction to the
court about what to do when that is not
available so that's similar to the one
we had flagged
before and then I
believe in dash
eight I'll find where it is on here for
18 yes um page six line I think 16
through 18 um that has that same
shortage as
expressed um and then never nonetheless
and that uh conforms
here three the the top of page six of
y and I'm happy I think those are the
changes I'm happy to look at the itic
and how they flow through and put that
together as notes afterwards um since we
will be coming back because I did that
for division one on another large bill I
was involved in so so there are multiple
Pages thereafter that's all just copy
from the underlying bill yeah and even
though he's got page seven and eight in
the in the U Amendment they're the
same okay
so it actually doesn't sound like it's
all that much more it sounds like it
it's
at in many ways of implementing the
innocent until proven guilty Theory um
but um all right so at this
point uh Miss Manzano
Miss masio sorry Manzano I'm gonna turn
you into an Italian I
think oh that works Manan
no um
so okay so I I don't want you to have to
redo everything representative leyon did
but if you picked up on some things that
we missed or or whatever just supplement
don't
replace yes so I'm not here to endorse
this amendment necessarily but I I did
have a lengthy conversation with
representative H
yesterday
um just a couple things I wanted to
point out from U Can I can I time out I
would first appreciate it if you would
just tell us what you think
representative hole was thinking I think
that was what you're about to do I would
not even dare no no I want you to wander
into that jungle U but but but from
there I I do I think we do want to know
what you think so but I just want to
keep it distinct between explaining what
you think he trying to do and keep that
distinct from what you the OCA thinks we
should do I don't want to get
confused the OCA thinks you should adopt
the bill as we wrote it but that's a
separate story um Christa and I both
also had conversations with Aaron cran
who unfortunately had to run out so I do
know that some of these amendments
representative H had talken to had
spoken to Aaron right before he spoke to
me so we might also need need to channel
Aon crean here because I think some of
this language the contrary to the
welfare language in particular and that
chunk the none the less chunk came from
the Judiciary so so Miss Morris I think
you're being invited to channel Aaron
Creek I feel like between the two of us
we can Channel Aaron
um
so as far as that section you guys were
just talking about which should be
section four can you can you do line
item or line numbers because that's
easier in representative H's Amendment
section one so we're looking at lines 5
through 14 that section which should be
identical
[Music]
to page 4
n and I think although they are not
identical in one of
those no instate option exists was
crossed
out and new words were put in but they
they mean essentially the same thing
however that last sentence that you guys
were just talking about I think the
struggle is in the draft in the original
text said any elud placement shall be
limited in time and require increased
judicial oversight because that
references back to that final section of
the bill um they then inserted that
require the written approval of the
director of DCF which is a section from
18573 so I think just where it got
inserted into the middle of that
sentence is Right makes it read weird um
but the point was that increased
judicial oversight is then described at
length in that last section that didn't
change that's very long so I think
that's why that part's confusing I think
you could switch that Clause around and
you get what you're looking for Jess
should require increas increased
judicial oversight and the written
approval then I like that because that's
that's what I was going to say I think
it's just the fact that I got stuck in
the middle of the sentence made it read
really weird I'm an old bureaucrat
things have to be signed a document
needs to be signed I want to know who's
going to sign it so nobody's signing
anything at the Judiciary based on that
sentence so so I like the
flip I agree um so this contrary to the
welfare language and actually it's also
in section two which is Page
115 uh lines 17 to 18 that language
comes out of current judicial language
some of the findings on the forums and I
believe it points to Federal language
the judges are used to making contrary
to the welfare findings it's not
necessarily A stricter ruling or a
heightened standard it's just the
language they're used to so I think that
came from Miss krian attorney krian the
bill originally was saying best interest
of the children because the
overarching 169 C language is best
interest it's also in
451a um so I I think there were many
places where the original bill was
worded best interest of the child
because that is language that's used
throughout 169c as that's the primary
determining factor is best interest so I
believe that was a request um from my
conversation with both Aaron and
representative h of the Judiciary that
the judges might find it confusing that
we're using best interest instead of
contrary to the welfare um I think in
the original drafting Senator Whitley
purposefully used best interest as a
standard I wouldn't say it's necessarily
higher lower equal as contrary to the
welfare
it just has a different flavor and
because that is the general overarching
purpose of
169c in this section um the whole every
reference is best interest so again
that's a policy decision that was made
it was a I believe a comment from the
Judiciary we don't take a position on
that but I did just want to point out I
don't believe it was meant to be a
higher or different standard it was just
language the judici Sherry felt more
forms and I think just part of their
business pract or not business practice
but their practice in general that's it
seemed like a comfort level thing
um in the discussion Tuesday which I
understand you weren't here for um
unfortunately representative Edwards
there was a lengthy discussion about how
to define unique needs um in my
conversations with representative who he
land am I saying that correctly
whole never okay I'm sorry I feel like I
say never gotten mad at me every time
um I I think D interim director Marie
Nunan kind of described what the
Department's practices are around unique
needs I thought she described it very
eloquently these are the words that
represent ofh picked out of that
discussion they're not necessarily all
of the words that were used during that
discussion um but I think it was part of
those conversations that unique needs
wasn't
defined
um on page two line
26 again I think this was just
referencing contrary to the welfare
versus best interest obviously the
original Bill used the term best
interest for
reason the kin fictive kin I think you
guys have discussed that at length pause
just a second uh so what is the current
standard in the Judiciary is it contrary
to the welfare of the child or best
interest of the child what's the what's
the standard way it's currently
described it it's both are used contrary
to the welfare is a specific finding
that the court has to make related to
Federal fore funding yeah however best
interest is also used throughout 169 see
when you're determining the needs of
children so I I think because there's
that specific contrary to the welfare
finding and again I'm sorry tring krian
had to leave right that's a term the
court has and uses on a checkbox form
however best interest is used quite a
bit within the statute and was
specifically used here for a reason I
guess you'd have to ask Senator Whitley
um but best interest is the overarching
umbrella if you look at the definitions
in 169c it is the best interest the
safety the well-being the welfare of the
child it's not the it's it's not the
contrary to the welfare is not used in
the beginning definition sorry getting
lost in the
words go ahead um so in looking at that
kin fictive kin I think representative
Mooney uh called attention to that fact
that again um interim director Marie
Nunan Tuesday it is a term of artart
that is is used in dcyf practice and
policy um it is part of kin as defined
in
17025 which is actually Mis misquoted on
page four line
15 um you are correct that that
definition was read is defined in
statute as kin but I believe director
Nunan you know testified on Tuesday that
fictive Kim is a term of art that is
recognized within the agency and used
when evaluating because there there is a
difference between kin and fictive kin
in that typically one's a blood relative
and one's not however I think we
discussed at length on Tuesday what that
difference can
mean um so so my reaction to this is
still kind of the same sort of uh
computer science driven thing if we're
going to incorporate by reference a
specific RSA then we should be
consistent with how the RSA defines the
term and if there's not a reference for
a term we shouldn't be using that term
if it needs its own
definition what that's a statement but
do you have a reaction to that I do not
have a reaction to that so so but you're
saying 17 the- G25 is a wrong reference
170e as an elephant 25 is the correct
one on page four line 15 it says G
instead of e oh
Echo sorry I I like
pads okay represent money thank you I
have in front of me
RSA 170 hyphen e colon 25 then Roman 8
which incidentally I think Roman 8
should be included in all of these
reference RSA references to Ken and I'd
like to read it to the committee the
definition kin means a child or children
who who for which there is a connection
or history between a child or their
parents and another responsible adult
adults show your point
I I think we're all getting a
long my point is that Roman 8 should be
incorporated Incorporated wherever the
RSA is and if everyone's in agreement I
do I would concur that kin is perhaps
all
inclusive uh to the language we're
looking for because it does reference
non blood
related adults thank
you
this I I I'm hopeful yes this is I think
one um all right keep going uh I did
Skip something in my excitement about
kin and fictive kin um on page we are
discussing the amendment though right I
mean no but I'm I'm responding to
represent wer I I I don't know that
we've ever discussed this amendment this
okay all right all right I I Now
understand I'll
quit all right got your your point is
Wellen keep going um sorry so back to
page one
um lines 24 to 31 um that
section we had a lengthy conversation on
Tuesday as well about innocence or guilt
this is not a criminal statute 169c is
is civil
I would point out that all of
169c the standard is preponderance of
the evidence clear and convincing is a
substantially higher criminal type
standard that is not used in abuse and
neglect cases so it would be a very
large deviation from current law and not
one that the OCA would be able to
support to change that to clear okay so
now you're you're crossing over from Yes
uh being analytical
having an opinion which is fine I just
was analytical 169 C all preponderance
of the evidence all right
of um I I think representative Leon
described the changes to G
um okay OCA does not agree with that all
right are we wrapped up on this um I
think the only other part that was
discussed so again that contrary to the
welfare language goes throughout we did
um amongst the advocacy groups talk
about that language then nonetheless if
there's no kin fictive kin order of
placement that the court should make a
temporary placement that language was a
request of the Judiciary but that
language does support the rest of that
that paragraph and and sort of follows
through to allow the court to say but
what do we do if there isn't a placement
so that was the same in two
sections
um I think that was a bulk of the
conversations that representative hle
okay so at this point what I'd like to
do is unless somebody really has
something more to say on 47 I'd like to
park it I'm going to encourage
representative H H to listen in on the
on the zoom the video of this I'm going
to ask representative H to be
accountable for whether or not he wants
to change his Amendment uh and and then
on Tuesday we'll come in part of what
we'll do is we'll listen to
representative
whole relative to his Amendment and and
and I representative wer I just assume
wait till Tuesday to to vote on your
Amendment so that's fine okay so so I
think we're done with
417 that's
456 repayment program for qualified
nursing
professionals 456 okay
um but um sidebar is good what do we
to on my amend oh we'll keep talking and
we'll come back Tuesday morning well I'm
not going to be here so I will just say
that say that um we had discussed
something with representative wer that I
was supportive of but represent walner
and represent wer know my opinion okay
so we got a subcommittee of two okay
um
456 um
who wants to start talking about
this I think this this feels like it it
could be
important but it clashes with some
principles of um picking winners and
losers and using general funds to pay
for reimbursing the loans of college
people when lots of people are plumbers
and didn't go to college so I I'm I'm
I'm a little turned off by SP 456
because of that who wants to tell me I'm
wrong and why I will go ahead you are
are you kidding me you think I'm wrong
you knew I was going to raise my hand
chman um no I'll just since you were're
not here for the public hearing I'll
just very briefly um share that this is
what I believe is a small
$300,000 appropriation to expand the um
nurse loan repayment program to try to
boost the um uh Workforce situation for
nursing Professionals in more rural
areas of the state
um this would help provide some coverage
in areas where there is shortage um we
talked about how the maximum Grant would
be 75,000 however not all grants are up
to that amount um it's somewhat flexible
um on what people would would be able to
you know qualify for and this is really
just a way to help with some of the
professional shortages we have in the
rural areas of the state where they
cannot attract enough um workers at the
it's an incentive to try to attract
people to these rural areas may I ask
you a question about that then um okay
so as I understand it for the purposes
of tele medicine we wrote into New
Hampshire law that all of New Hampshire
is considered Rural and therefore
eligible for tele medicine efforts and
so as I look at these definitions of
underserved areas it makes me wonder how
targeted this would be would would it
really be targeted at those zip codes
perhaps that we know have an lack of
Manpower and that we're trying to move
the needle in those places that we have
known gaps I'm I'm concerned that maybe
we're using an overly broad definition
and we're bringing in to the
eligibility uh you know somebody that's
in Rockingham County for example that
you know technically Rockingham County
is rural but it's really not so so who
is there somebody who can speak to the
up refer to the online lrp and I think
no I've read it that's why I'm concerned
because I I see it's referencing
definitions and I but I don't know what
the detailed definitions are beneath
that though hi hi there so I'm all in
favor of targeted to make sure that
where we have Manpower shortages that
this money is being focused on fixing
those shortages I want to be careful
that we're not wasteful that everyone is
eligible by default and we're not using
the money to the very best Advantage so
what what can you tell us about
definitions and the like yeah so um
State loan repayment eligibility is
limited to um sites and areas that sit
in a federally designated shortage area
so it's not just you know this loose
term of rural areas what does that mean
in New Hampshire we talk about rural
because many of our rural areas are
designated as medically you sound
nervous it's okay this is a very
friendly I know
I way and then I ease into it it's like
this every time all
right it's hard when you're sitting
there and your heart rate is so low too
and um so yes there are strict uh
guidelines and and uh Federal federally
um uh
federally excuse me Federal federally
designated shortage areas excuse me are
based on um provider Supply and
population um metrics that reveal a
shortage of primary care providers in an
area um and as I said you know
eligibility for the program is
restricted primarily to shortage Des
shortage areas um because you know that
status rites
need okay uh for the committee has
anyone proposed an amendment my note
says that there no amendments were
proposed for 456 right okay so um so
this to me there there's there's an
intriguing and valuable thought behind
this you know we we need to make sure
the Manpower is deployed to where the
needs are totally get that MH you've
you've made me a little bit more
comfortable that it's not a broad brush
painting of the state
okay I I think I would like to propose
we sunset this and I don't have a sunset
length of time in my head right now
three years four years so that um so
that this program has to be relooked at
after we have more experience with it
because we have a theory we do X Y will
happen right so we're we're spending X
and hoping y happens so I'd kind of like
to do a Sunset and a report so that we
know what
happened yeah so um I think what's not
clear is that the um amended legislation
there's two parts of it um one is to
appropriate 300,000 towards an existing
program that's existed for 25 years
years the second component is a report
for the state to investigate a separate
program that would be stood up to you
know solely fund um nurses loan
repayment for nurses um irrespective of
specialty setting or
location so representative Mooney being
the left side of my brain uh the
analytical side does the sunset in this
um sure I'm open to that I I can see the
value in that um I'd be interested in
what other have to say but um it would
seem like a maybe a good start could I
can I clarify I'm Abby Rogers
legislative Lin could I just ask what
the sunset is on the the slurp program
the existing program for 25 years or is
it on the proposed budget proposal for
the additional program that wouldn't the
additional incremental program okay so
the way we read the legislation at that
came over from the Senate is at this
point the the one time I think the
intent of Senator Ganon was to have a
separate program outside of the slurp
program that would be administered by
the department that would not would
apply to those other nurses that were
not in the medically underserved or
rural areas but this is any any nurse in
New Hampshire and we have this program
the slurp program which is for medically
underserved areas so that did not look
like something that was going to go
forward in the Senate and as a result um
the compromise was that the Senate
appropriated 300,000 to go into the
existing slurp program with a reporting
requirement that the department would
come up with a budget proposal and what
this other program um to cover nurses
that weren't in medically underserved
areas might look
walner well I she just addressed really
what I was going to ask and that is I
would not want to see us putting any
sort of sunet
on the program that we've had for 25
years no we want to be very very careful
about that okay good represent L I just
wanted to say you know this is just an
additional $300,000 to the existing
program and I guess if you did want to
Sunset something I would need some
strong clear clarification on what
you're sunsetting the increment this
program is changing eligibility is it
not no expanding the elig
no it's just $300 of additional money to
the program period that's it yes it's a
line item to give them an extra $300,000
what you've already spent all the money
we gave you already yes that's right all
of that's that's the bottom line you've
already spent all the money all of the
yes all of the um General funds and so
you want another 300,000 that is that
really what this is no so Senator Ganon
wanted to expand it to a different a
separate Pro parallel program to the
slurp program and as a result he uh
has an interest in um helping student
nurses that need student loan repayment
so the Senate said in in addition U that
it wasn't feasible outside of a budget
year to consider a separate program but
300,000 solely dedicated to nurses um
license under one um RSA 326b the nurse
PR Practice Act this would be an
additional one-time appropriation to our
existing program to support just nurses
are there any other comments represent
string well just comment there's there's
no money to write the report that's due
by November 1st but I imagine the
department can handle it but uh in the
existing appropriation but I think the
idea is to is to look at expanding it
and somebody's going to write a report
the 300,000 entirely goes into the
existing yeah loan loan forgiveness
program representative f it looks like
question well first of all I I I thought
some explaining the this the funding of
this slurp is that what you call it yeah
is federal is that correct no that's
it's just generally funded so where did
I get that misimpression there is
Chairman there are federal state loan
repayment programs we uh developed our
own to sort of avoid those prescriptive
um you know guidelines they don't pay
for administrative support also which of
course you need Administration to run
the program um and so we yep built our
own 25 years ago and this is a
$75,000 per person which means really
four people could suck it all up um the
75,000 is for tier one providers that
actually does exclude aprns um aprns are
tier 2 RNs are tier three um really it
would be funding about six contracts
which doesn't sound significant unless
you really look you know break it down
to the numbers um the average number of
patients that an APRN a primary care a
he that day is about 15 multiply that by
number of you know working days a year
3,900 times that by six that's about
25,000 um patients that would be
impacted through this
expansion and so I I'm I also serve on
the Hillsboro County um executive
committee and there are quite a
few programs at least in Hillsboro I'm
guessing across the state for nurse
training for instance the the County
nursing home here does it for they pay
you to do it and they you so
are is this really is this program
really necessary given all the other
programs that are in place for
specifically for bringing nurses up and
and training them yes because it's to
incentivize these Primary Care Providers
to practice in locations that there is a
dir of primary care providers such as
Rural and medically underserved
areas you say pcps I think that as a
doctor you're talking about nurses
though right yep y aprns and Primary
Care RNs also that work in an outpatient
setting um in again those underserved
areas such as where uh Coos County just
about every every town in Coos County um
many most of New Hampshire I don't have
a map for you today but most of New
Hampshire um is designated as Rural and
not to say every rural not to say every
rural um area is also medically
underserved but that's sort of where we
point to the federal definition of a
shortage area because you know calculate
that they use these metrics to you know
determine that status so we fall back on
that and not you know reinvent the wheel
do it again because they have sort of
strict um guidelines that that are
formulated into that
calculation thank you if I could add an
addition I think some of the
conversation in the Senate hearing was
around um helping nurses maybe start
their careers in New Hampshire with this
assistance and and choose to stay here
and continue their careers and and stay
in
state right but you're not trying to
just get some to stay in the state
because obviously we have a lot of
programs specifically specifically for
that and they're from my understand
working very well you're trying to get
them
to Canada essentially not to Canada but
up to that part of the state well there
are this also covers I believe
Behavioral Health Specialists there are
areas even in Nashua and Manchester um
Community Mental Health Centers that
utilize these providers um because they
serve an underserved
population okay I find it hard to
believe you're having a problem getting
people in NASA because that's part of
Hillsboro County and I know we have
these programs nurses have a lot of
competing priorities at this time I
think what was what came up in the
Senate hearing was losing New Hampshire
nurses to traveling nurse opportunities
where the the pay is a lot can be a lot
greater to leave the state I get that
but how's this going to address that
problem well it's just an additional
funding source that the program would
have to to support nurses that need some
student loan repayment but this is just
to get them trained
correct no this is this is for providers
to practice in an area the contracts are
three years for full-time with um the
possibility of funding is available for
an additional two uh two years for a
contract extension and that's sort of go
ahead so these are nurses that are
already nurses yes and so what did you
say was the the the kind of people the
pcps yeah out patient Primary Care
Providers what would they be gen so what
how much would they get
as an
example um I don't know if I've
memorized here too we could probably
talking ballpark you're talking about
supplementing their salary is that
really what all this is doing as opposed
to
training it's no it's not supplementing
salary it it it would be to you know
help with that burden of of it would Hur
it would help with a loan burden
basically to incentivize them to
practice in these areas you know that
are hard to get providers to practice in
and don't pay as much as so they've
already paid for their training
yes and you believe this is going to get
them to it does it's actually a
nationally recognized um uh program that
is used as a tool throughout the nation
that's why we have the National Health
Service Corp um and the state loan
repayment program for for all of our
states um because of of the evidence
that suggests it is a powerful
Recruitment and Retention tool
I think you should talk to some of the
other like for instance hsbor County
nursing home about the approaches that
they take because really what we're
talking about is in my mind is bringing
the nurses in whether they're already
nurses or not already nurses getting
them trained and or if not necessarily
getting trained bringing them in but if
you can train them on the job which is
what we do um you know that sounds like
a more effective Approach at least it
seems more effective all you're talking
about here is a half a dozen people I
mean you get a lot of pay patients down
the road but we're talking about people
not not patients this is a this would be
a supplemental appropriation to what the
funding that we already do have through
the program to to to fund some
additional nursing recruits which I
thought you said was run
out it has that's right all of the
general funds for State fiscal year 25
have been committed um so it would just
expand I mean we do though have 100
contracts within the state so it would
just well I okay I'm confused with that
term contracts
you're talking about basically helping
contract the contract to participate in
the state loan repayment program so
between the state and the provider that
that they would move to Coos County get
a sign a contract for a job to work
there for three years and be able to
benefit from this program to have
assistance in paying their loans that
allowed them to get their degree
okay I guess I'm just still not
convinced this is the best way to bring
in more
nurses well if I may go ahead represent
ly what I just feel like we had a very
in-depth conversation at the public
hearing on this and uh or I'm sorry it
was a work session but on Tuesday and I
thought it was very enlightening and
it's a unique way to draw those
providers into those areas where we have
people who can't get medical care they
can't drive 90 minutes 3 hours hours
down to um get an appointment and we
just heard I I'm happy you shared those
that those numbers that this potentially
could have
25,000 uh patient visits which I think
would have a huge impact on these areas
that they're not they just don't have
access to Medical Care so so I see the
theory you know and and some rough
correlation between bringing in new
providers and additional patients being
served I get I I I get that I I I it
does doesn't sound to me like this
program is assured to deliver on that
though if this is essentially an in an
incremental benefit they're it's not
reimbursing them for college that
they're going to it's it's it's an
additional benefit for
them it ties them to this area that is
in such high need of providers yeah and
it says come and work in gorum or LAN
so let's say I'm a I'm already working
in in location x and x is one of these
underserved underman places let's let's
just say x and can am I eligible for to
sign this contract and to get this money
if I'm already INX yes you would be but
typically we don't see that we see new
providers coming in um for employment
because when you've worked somewhere for
an extended period of time typically
you've you know already paid your loans
back also so it's possible but we don't
see it it's typically you know new
providers that were recruiting to an
area and the reason they chose that you
know employer that practice site is
because of this um incentive to also you
know have their loans um paid as well so
so why is 300,000 the right number it
sounds like you you you know six people
who are left out in the cold and you're
trying to cover six you probably have a
by name list of six people right I I
think the history was that uh the the
program the this completely parallel
program that was in that was suggested
in the original Bill had a fiscal note
of1 18 million to set up a parallel
program to the one that we have now so
the Senate thought that was not going to
go forward outside of a budget year with
some technical issues to work out so
300,000 would support x amount of nurses
for until the end of the banum to give
something extra to the program because
we're so of the six additional people
that you probably have roughly
identified already by name
no no we don't have any money right I
know but they can still apply and you
can say hey I don't have any money they
haven't okay I I'm just trying to make
sure that I understand why 300,000 why
six that was a decision that the Senate
appropriated in the committee that was
just a decision yes it was so if we just
decided 150 that would just be another
decision
right yes all right representa wer most
of us that heard the original
presentation were quickly convinced that
this had enough safeguards we have a
report that's going to come in it's
going to tell us what was the effect how
many were affected did it help how many
visits stays and so on that was the that
was what we heard and I don't think any
of us felt we needed to amend it or
argue about it it just seemed like a
reasonable thing to do it's it's
attached to a existing program that's
been pretty successful but not enough
money so we put another 300,000 see what
an effect it had and see how it worked
out we've we've done this several places
I remember in my County we were training
lnas and we said you we'll send spend
this money training you but you'll have
to either sign up for a contract or pay
for the training and here comes exit to
hospital hey come work for us for
another Buck an hour and we'll pay this
money that you have to pay back that's
that's the kind of thing where so they
do contracts and hopefully they're
tighter than what we did at so so so far
we voted to spend another $7 million out
of um out of cycle I just wanted to put
that Benchmark out of there but it also
sounds like you have a motion you want
to make do you do you want to make a
motion I'll move on to pass I'll second
okay okay so um do you want to when
yes this is House Bill
456 I believe no Amendment or is it no
Amendment um the motion is a to pass
representative Mooney yes representative
F yes representative Leon yes chairman
Wier yes representative walner yes
representative tersi yes representative
Stringham says yes representative priest
yes chairman
Edwards yes vote being nine to zero the
motion
passes okay so
463 463 is expanding access to Corner
appointed Council for children
independency proceedings
excuse me Mr chair yes as to Senate Bill
456 just taken up will it be
representative Wier that takes charge of
you okay
so
um okay Mr chair on Senate Bill 456
representativ 463 excuse me 463
representative priest and I have a joint
amendment I think we'd probably like to
time oh then it's just representative
priest's amendment that he would like to
time thank you Mr chairman um do you
think we need a second to scan it skim
it I I I just I let me let me scam it
please
thank you Mr chairman um because of the
testimony we heard from the various
um staff and employees from the children
uh the judicial and the child protection
uh agencies on uh Tuesday of this week
representative and Mooney and I decided
that it would be best if we
con kind of Consolidated our thoughts
into one
Amendment and the language um that we
wanted to add
into uh section two of the
bill um
basically takes that section but adds in
um and that's starting at line six if an
attorney is not available for
appointment the court May proceed with
the litigation until an attorney becomes
available under appropriate
circumstances the court may consider
appointing a non attorney to a
temporary represent the child's express
interest until the attorney becomes
available the court may consider whether
it is it is possible to prioritize
consideration of legal issues that do
not affect the child's express interest
until the attorney becomes
available um this was because we heard
from the testimony that in order to do
this the objective objectives of this
bill there wasn't a need for additional
Staffing at
DHHS there is or is not there there is
not to do this to start up this program
and to um to see the effectiveness so
that's why we put this paragraph in MH
the second part was to amend the bill
taking out section
four and then ruming it section four was
the Staffing of this
bill and that is the amendment is there
is there there is no fiscal cost okay is
there discussion on
this m Miss
Rosenberg uh do you do you have anything
you want to add you don't have to but
I'm just giving you an
[Music]
opportunity um thank thank you for um
recognizing me I'm Karen rosberg policy
director disability rights Center I'm
Emily Lawrence I'm the deputy advocacy
director with Waypoint um so just
getting my head around this I think that
we expected the removal or substantial
amendment of section four of the bill
recognizing that um the fiscal note
seemed although there was no fiscal
impact for this banm that the fiscal
note going forward seemed hugely
inflated given that there's all of the
um a lot of the requirements are
actually already embedded in either
federal law or current DCF policy
um what I'm having difficulty with
though is this is the um provision above
that would basically establish a right
but not really establish a right can you
stick your finger on the line item yeah
so um I'm looking at the um proposed
amendment and starting at line
six if an attorney is not available for
appointment the court May proceed with
the litigation until attorney an
attorney becomes
available and under appropriate
circumstances the court may consider
appointing a non- attorney to
temporarily represent the child's
expressed interest until an attorney
becomes
available um I mean the rest of it just
flows from there like that section so
what is really concerning is that um
this bill as as um it came to you was
extremely narrowly tailored to recognize
that children who are placed in
institutional settings are the most
vulnerable of this segment of children
and that it is a Paramount importance
that those children have counsil to
represent their expressed
interests and um New Hampshire is an
outlier here we're the one of only six
states in the whole country that never
ever provide a right to counsel for
children and so in narrowly tailoring
this um bill that as it came to you
the idea was that we are going to pick
only the most you know the most
vulnerable children in the most
vulnerable situations whose rights to
family Integrity to being able to live
in their homes and communities to be
able to attend their schools like these
very fundamental aspects of a child's
life when those are being removed or
threatened to be removed that that is of
such importance that Council ought to be
appointed what this um Amendment would
do is basically say well we don't really
mean that um because we're we're because
it provides an out it says well you know
if we can't find someone then you're not
going to have this right and in every
other case where coun where the
legislature the US Supreme Court have
determined that someone is entitled to
courta appointed counsel those cases
don't proceed until council is appointed
so you know in a criminal case in a
juvenile case where like a juvenile
delinquency case where kids are entitled
to counsel because they may lose their
Liberty they may be removed from their
parents' homes they may be um you know
placed in an Institutional setting in
the juvenal case where the behavior is
technically that child's you know
valtion if they're found true they get
an attorney but in this case it would be
saying well we think this is an
important right you're here for no
reason that you didn't cause this you
didn't cause your parents to abuse you
right it's not this is this isn't your
it wasn't your doing um but you know
we're going to take you out of your home
we're going to remove you from your
school we're going to put you in an
institution and although we think that's
really important for kids who are in the
juvenile delinquency system that they
have counsel maybe not for you I think I
hear the concern about you know are we
going to have an adequate pool of
attorneys but this Bill does not become
effective for over a year from now there
is plenty of time to gear up here and
we're not talking about hordes of
Children Here currently there are about
124 children who would be appointed
counsel so I'm really finding this very
very difficult okay thank you thank you
for your comments I I'm going to let
representative Mooney and priest um
explain what they think this does but as
I've read it and I've just seen it what
I'm what I'm reading is a little
different than what I heard you describe
uh I what I'm what I'm reading is that
we really want to create a client
attorney relationship in these cases but
in the harsh negative reality of there
not being an attorney involved that we
would like to continue to process the
cases uh with the flexibility and the
guidance to the Judiciary that they
should postpone or or set aside the most
critical issues if they think a council
could be determinative and how that case
gets resolved and if and if that's true
then you know I it feels to me like we
we we want there to be an an attorney
present but in case there isn't let's
keep moving forward and if there's
something critical you know then let's
let's postpone that case until we can
get legal counsel assigned that that's
the way I read this representative
priest do you do you want to comment
since you your this is your bill yeah
you you basically uh summarized it very
well and that was our purpose we saw the
need for this the need is there we see
the need for attorneys representing
these children but if an attorney isn't
available at that time then we'll we'll
find someone to help process their
concerns until an attorney can be found
I mean that was the that was the
objective yeah do you we're not
dismissing these children right I agree
I I I hear you I I hear the emotion in
your voice too so so it's okay
representative Mooney do you do you you
work together what would would you
classify what this any differently than
it's been described but no I concur with
that there's been a lawyer shortage for
quite some time now in New Hampshire
that is a reality I would be interested
in hearing Miss
krian thank you so miss krian you're on
Deck you're going to come up but
representative Wallner do you do you
have comment no I just I have a question
I just wondered if this has come up
either an amendment like this or this
concept has come up in any of the other
uh policy committees that this has gone
through I mean has anyone else looked at
this the idea that we're
short the idea that they're is could be
difficulty recruiting attorneys I think
it's something that did come up however
I think the answer to that was to
postpone the effective date for a year
it's I think that's no guarantee though
right if I could just say there was an
amendment that was brought in children
and family law that was had um one of I
think similar to one of the lines here
and that was not passed by children and
family
law followup representative lski
okay so thank you I know I know this is
an important subject you and I have
talked about this offline and I I I I
think we're trying to move in a
direction that addresses the concern in
a reality-based
world um I mean I I I hear what you're
saying I guess I mean one thing that I
that I mean I and I also see what where
you're heading I I mean I I understand
where you're going representative priest
I think that you know while this would
provide the court may consider whether
it's possible um to prioritize
consideration of other legal issues it
doesn't wouldn't require that and also
the idea that a non-attorney I think we
need trained attorneys like any other
really fundamental right someone who's
entitled to an attorney needs to be able
to have a trained attorney it's possible
that there could be training for
non-attorneys and that could be a
separate matter but I I I don't know it
feels very late in the game before
that's all figured out to be amending
this
soly would you believe that I sat on
corporate legal offices as a non-
attorney as a worldwide subject matter
expert on privacy and I didn't need to
be an attorney to be a worldwide expert
and I know that there are programs now
even in our state that allow
non-attorney Advocates to appear in
court um in certain matters
so I think I'm just not I don't have my
head around that yet for this one it
seems like a pretty big departure from
where the policy committee had been on
this all right thank you are there any
other questions from division three then
miss
krian and I'm not thank you so much both
of you for coming
up what what would you like to tell us
about this good afternoon Mr chair
members of committee thank you very much
for considering this amendment uh this
is a this is a practical limit itation
for the courts that we simply want to
make sure that we have direction from
the legislature about what we do if an
extremely likely probability comes to
pass uh the the courts would love for
everyone to have an attorney it only
makes things more efficient and better
in the courts there's there's no
preference from the courts for anyone to
ever foro attorney representation um and
and we very much like everyone to have
access to attorneys but unfortunately
that's not what happens if you sit in a
district court and and wait for people
who are waiting for their Conflict
attorneys because they can't be
represented by the public defender they
call the case not ready they call it the
next week not ready they call it the
next week not ready um people are
waiting for justice in the state of New
Hampshire because of our attorney
shortage but in a criminal case the only
affected party is the defendant in abuse
and neglect cases there are parents
there are children there are multiple
people who are affected SO waiting for
the child's attorney delays the entire
case and universe of people and not only
are there statutory deadlines that the
legisl has given the courts to move
these cases along there are also Federal
deadlines a oneyear deadline ask you a
theoretical question let's let's say um
a year from now uh this bill is in place
and a supply of lawyers has appeared in
order to meet the terms of this uh if
the attorneys were available this
paragraph would never be in effect is
that true if an attorney is available
all of this language is unneeded it's
it's it's just extra language that
doesn't get used it is only if we have a
situation where an attorney is not
available so so this is kind of like a
break glass
option we don't want to do this we don't
want to break the glass but this gives
us the ability to do it so we can keep
cases moving through the system the
courts very much want to comply with the
legislator's desire to have attorneys
for children we just may not be able to
find them is is there anyone in the
department that wants to speak to this
you don't have to okay do you have a
question yes I do Mr chairman uh
if if the language of the bill passes
versus this amendment if an attorney is
not available does that mean that a
child would be staying with a
potentially abusive parents instead of
being placed in a
home I it should not um I I think what
would practically happen I'm guessing if
if if if this statute were simply silent
as to what to do if there's no attorney
is that the case will go through 30 to
60 days of halted jilted uh difficult
proceedings before eventually it has to
proceed anyway
ahead and and where would the child be
during that time period I think that
they would probably be placed or they
have to they have to be removed right
away from the abusive situation so it's
either temporary or permanent placement
but keep in mind um although I I I see
the value and I know that The Advocates
certainly see the value of having an
attorney that these children are
represented by Guardians dead Lim for
their best interests the addition of the
attorney is for their expressed
interests when they want something
different than the guardian ID item has
determined is in their best interest so
so the term uh justice Deni or delayed
as Justice denied is jumping around in
my head and this sounds like okay the
best case is this but we don't want to
pay for it at the cost of delaying the
system the the legislature could
certainly say halt the case and do
nothing until there is an attorney but
we will be in violation of other
deadlines that you have said and that
the federal government has set for these
cases wer representative
wer I'm pretty sure I remember some of
the testimony on this that
cause representative priest to volunteer
to write the the amendment was a lot of
people said this seems ridiculous 14 new
child protective service workers am I
right that we heard that that was we
heard testimony why do we need so many
of them added you know it's if it's 124
children what what do we need these 14
Child Protective Service workers and you
know maybe we do need the attorneys but
uh do we need five of them for 124
children it so but especially that child
protective service worker right pretty
sure that we heard that was way in
excess of what most of the people that
dealt with this thought were necessary
so thank you for writing the amendment
because we're not getting into that
quite so Mr Ripple with this amendment
does this basically uh remove the fiscal
note for for the most part for fiscal
year 25 yes there may still be Staffing
increases needed when this bill goes
into effect July 1st 2025 but the
department would need to include those
in their uh operating budget request 26
fiscal 26 sorry yes
okay all right so are there any other
comments
questions I think are we ready for a
motion would somebody like to make thank
you for coming I I hope you enjoy your
Friday this is all I do this is
fun go ahead represent priest yes I move
that we approve um
Amendment um 20 24-
189h for SB
463 second okay second so uh since it's
favor okay I see seven up
okay so having passed the amendment is
otpa go ahead representative priest Mr
chairman
I I'm sorry Mr chairman I move ought to
pass as amended SB
second um when you're ready to take a
recorded vote Mr clerk motion is auto
passes amended Ed by Amendment
189h
um uh put forward by representative
priest and seconded by money
representative Mooney yes representative
F yes representative Leon
yes chairman Wier yes representative
walner representative tersi yes
representative Stringham is yes
representative priest yes chairman
Edwards yes
okay so that's nine nothing but let's
blurb okay so I got priest and although
we just voted unanimously for an otpa
does anyone think that there's a re
reason for a Minority Report to talk
about the amendment and the opposition
to the
amendment
no all right just asking
if if you got you got days to think
about it um all right all
right so be because if there's going to
be opposition on the floor then it would
be good to have the house calendar with
the report to explain the basis of the
argument that that's all I'm thinking
but you're it's up to you on what how
you want to handle
that go
ahead Mike though
we don't know that we won't get some
opposition
from um the other committee that
had a similar amendment that turned it
also would it be possible but they don't
get to write they don't get to write the
blur that's what I'm saying no they
don't get to write the blur right true
but they do get to speak on the floor if
they want oh sure okay sure um would it
be possible to take like a 10minute
break just yeah we can take a a a recess
for 10 minutes and uh there's only two
bills left and the way I look at these
two bills it really ought not take a
long time yeah I I need about 10 or 15
minutes at four o'clock but so oh but uh
so can we make it five minutes okay
let's let's recess
to
e
all right so it's uh 3:38 the recess was
to 337 so um we're going to come out of
motion is there a motion on
567 yes Mr chair I'll make a motion uh I
notice some some of our members are not
here to hear it so um hopefully they see
that we're online and we're in action so
I can make the motion that everybody's
hang
nice color tie there represented priest
yeah yeah yeah yeah you went with the
IBM look though I I did sort of a fancy
look at that do oh you don't know that
old saw about the IBM guys they all wore
white shirts and
and blue coats Blue
Jackets
yeah
Day so I'd like to finish um so uh We've
we've come out of recess already uh
there's a about to be a motion on on SP
567 okay thank you Mr chair I would like
to move s SP 567 as
itl set out can I have two seconds I
apologize no that's all right uh and
then so we have a motion on the floor
itl of 567 and is there discussion do
you need a moment to be prepared to
I had my brain in the other room on
another bill so I just needed to get my
head
together it's all
right I I want your brain engaged
representative walner uh do you have
remarks or discussion just you know
briefly I think that there's value in um
a doing a report like this and I think
that there are
probably I mean I don't think the
department really
felt equipped to do it they didn't seem
there didn't seem to be any
Interest really in moving forward with
them doing it but I do think there might
be
contract organizations out there that
they could contract with to um to have
it done and um you know it seems like
there would be be value in that may I
tell you my rationale on why I'm
comfortable with an
itl uh one it seems like it's new work
to the department by new work I mean
it's it's it's a new function it's a new
role it's a new way of B doing business
and and and there would be a learning
curve if we wanted to expand the scope
of work of the
department um also as I understand it um
the these two drugs were uh reviewed in
courts in the Texas court and an appell
at court and there's now a decision a
decision in front of the Supreme
Court the Texas Court federal court
determined that the FDA in approving
these
Two drugs did not um meet their
standards of of FDA approval for safety
and efficacy that they they uh
apparently I I'm this is not the legal
term but they may have sh taken some
shortcuts to get an approval before it
was cooked and Texas put in place an
injunction because of that the appell at
court did not dispute that the FDA had
um shortcut the the process for safety
and efficacy but they did dispute
whether or not an injunction was
appropriate so I think the decision in
the Supreme Court is whether or not the
injunction was correct but but the the
fact finding a fact was that FDA didn't
do their normal safety and
efficacy and so um and and there's 's
also this issue of these the companies I
don't even know who makes these two
drugs it could be two companies or could
be multiple companies but um but those
are those are billion dooll corporations
billion dollar corporations have huge
marketing departments I don't I don't I
don't know that we should be in the
business of you know facilitating a
marketing budget so for those Reasons
I'm comfortable with an
itto any other comments
yes I'll just say that I'll be voting
against the itl um
I we discussed a little bit on Tuesday
about um these drugs have been used for
a number of years um effectively to um
also assist when women um have a
miscarriage or a pregnancy um
unexpectedly terminates and um they have
been proven to be very effective
and I want to make sure that we have all
the information needed um to ensure that
these drugs are available uh when women
need them that's it thank you if the
department the FDA had gone through the
standard safety and efficacy clinical
trials protocols and they had determined
appropriately that it was effective I
would agree with you but but they didn't
um and so so having the state pushing
for any drug I don't I don't I'm not
talking about the purpose of the drug
I'm just saying you know the safety and
efficacy are important functions of the
FDA and it isn't that if we if I mean
Health Care Providers can still
prescribe these these things are still
these pills are still
available uh we're not inhibiting the
Health Care System we're just not trying
to get in between the health care
provider and the patient the health care
Fe profession and Physicians are you
know can make their own determination
what's in the patient's best interest I
don't think we need to weigh in on that
that so so we just disagree but that
that may be the first uh okay
so is there more
discussion if you're ready for a vote
this house bill 567 the motion Bill I'm
sorry Senate Bill 567 the motion is
itl um representative Mooney yes
representative F
yes representative Leon yes
representative Wier yes representative
walner yes
no I'll put that as a no maybe no I jump
to the next is that yes yes I put no is
that okay no no yes it's no
Representative
tersi no representative Stringham says
no representative priest
no uh chairman Edwards yes uh the vote
being five to four the motion passes
again that was a Mooney and Earth and um
you want to handle the jacket so I'll
I'll go ahead and write the blurb on
that um you know I think people are
tired of punching me so I can write
that uh okay so uh let's move on to S SP
596 relative to the definition of
disability or special needs under the
child care scholarship program my note
on this says that representative walner
will work on a new fiscal
note did you did you do that I did okay
do you want to talk about that and maybe
refresh us on what the uh bill is trying
to do I think Kevin has a I have an
okay so we're trying to finish by four
because we lose representative string
and I'll talk fast
okay and then you still want to talk
about 499 in a a brief intro just brief
yes okay um
if you remember this is the bill where
children with
um special
needs are in child care and child care
providers may need to
provide special things for those kids
they may
need a little bit of oneon-one
attention from the provider every day
meaning that the provider has to
increase their Staffing slice
they may need they may need some special
kinds of
equipment um they may need some extra
hands when they go out for a walk they
may need extra hands if they go on a
field trip in the bus um you know just
any number of things that you might need
if you had a child
who came to you who had some special
needs often these often these are are
kids who maybe have some difficulties in
the group they may have some behavioral
problems um it might be nice to have an
extra person sit with them at Circle
time so that they aren't touching
everybody or you know interrupting and
and just providing that extra help that
those kids need early when they're
little I mean we're talking little we're
talking kids who are two years old um
and helping them adjust into the child
care setting and hopefully if they can
do that in those early preschool
years that'll help them get ready for
school and they won't need as much
special help in public school which we
know becomes very expensive so this is
really PR kind of preventative the
Department of Health and Human Services
already has a program like this there
are already some children in
it um it takes a certain level of
professional to make the decision as to
whether they're the children are going
to be classified to get this special
differential rate
um what this does is allowed for a
developmental screening tool to be used
and I brought one with me so you can see
it the one that I'm familiar with mostly
is ages and stages and it's a checklist
that um and most of them work like this
it's a checklist that both the teacher
in the trial care center and the parent
do each of them do it and then uh look
at what those how that turns out some
children there are no issues some
children might need a little help um to
be able to to stay in their childcare
setting so and what the amendment does
is
basically say that the department may
use federal funds for
available so if they have federal funds
that are available for this um and like
I said there's already a program like
this that exist at the department um and
to use General funds from within the
Department's existing budget we're
talking about this being a very small
number of children in a very small
allocation I think the bill came to us
with like an estimate of 375,000 a year
and I really think it'll be much less
than that right now I think they're only
monthly they're only spending on the
children that are in the program now
they're only spending between 50 and
$60,000 a month
comment I'm ready for
comment okay
um I I I I hear you say that this will
affect a relatively few number of kids
and I think the quantification of how
big a population that may be would be
dependent upon what assessment tool was
selected and you brought an assessment
tool but I don't think we're going to be
able to read it in three minutes so so
um so given that we're we're modifying
the definition and and by that we're
probably expanding the pool of eligible
kids uh uh I I I don't know that we have
enough information to really figure out
what the impact is on the population
being
served uh and and the fact that we're
not there is no code a formal diagnostic
or formal special education code to
capture this
category it feels to me it just feels to
me this is a reaction not an analysis
but it just feels to me like
um it's a little variable and subject to
interpretation the way it is now on who
would be eligible and and and I I I
would rather see
this uh Bill along with your Amendment
taken to interim study that would be my
preference but but out of deference to
you because we're short on time and I
don't want to for force you into a vote
here when it's
premature can you or would you be
willing to have us recess this until
Tuesday
morning so that we can take a look at
the assessment tool because I would need
to talk to my folks
about the impact of that assessment tool
in terms
of whether or not
it it you know what it's going to do to
the size of the uh serve
population so how would you like to
proceed okay I I
am I am only bringing one assessment
tool there are many out there that the
department would I I believe the way the
bill is at this point is that the
department would U make the decision as
to what kinds of assessment tool they
would accept so I'm only bring I'm not
I'm not suggesting this is
the end all and be all this is just one
that I'm familiar with that I brought
forward so you could see it right
because I knew that was a question
people had um I will tell you because I
checked with some people this morning
before I came that
um there is a before any provider can
receive this kind of reimbursement
there's a fairly specific um
verification that the department has the
provider go through and even um saying
how they will use the extra funds to
integrate this child into their into
their program so what what would your
preference be would you like to make
your motion and vote now or would you
prefer to wait till Tuesday morning so
that we have time to talk to more people
I guess I I guess I'll take my chances
and and come back on Tuesday because if
we vote now I don't think I have the
votes um at this this point but so maybe
I'm wrong so with with your with with
your acquiescence uh not permission but
agreement let's let's go ahead I want to
uh recess s SP 496 to Tuesday Morning um
and where we can we can bring it back up
and um Miss Morris would would you would
you find somebody to make me smart on
the variability of the assessment tools
and what what the assessment tools may
do to increase the
population uh that would be served can
you are you able to do that by Wednesday
night or Monday night
rather okay all right so um all right so
we're going to we're going to recess on
4117 till Tuesday morning we're going to
recess on SB 596 until Tuesday Morning
um I think we're going to schedule that
at 10:00 a.m. that that'll give us two
hours I I don't mean to repow a lot of
the ground on 47 I just wanted us to be
prepared to know what we think yes sir
so clarification uh 10:00 on Wednesday
yes no no no no Tuesday Monday Tuesday
Monday okay so so so just just to
explain what's going on right full
Finance has so many things in division
one that there that's Monday afternoon
division three is
Tuesday for our bills so we have to be
finished you know before noon or
whatever so to to to hand off to
division uh the full finance committee
all the division three bills okay and
for Republicans Tu Monday morning at
noon like to have a box okay so so let's
I I know I know you're eager to go uh
can you can you do us a flyby on what
well representative
Tori has an amendment that um basically
adds back in the
B EBT I'm sorry i s Su EBT the summer
EBT and um it adds it back in for um
just as it came to us from the Senate so
um that that's what we're thinking I
know there is been some other work done
by the department on uh a couple of
other amendments which I have to look I
really have to have a few minutes to
really look at those closer but we're
thinking in terms of at adding to the
elderly part that you've already passed
adding to that of the summer EBT for
children starting in the summer of 24
represent tki I sense you want to say
something no I just want to clarify what
the intention is so this division passed
um an amendment with your name on it I
think yes that was
just um the elderly application right I
have a different amendment that H
includes your Amendment but adds summer
EBT so my conclusion would be that
um this my Amendment would be in place
of the amendment that this division
already saw
okay so because we didn't have this on
today's House calendar I don't really
think we should talk about it much more
um and so my thought on this we have we
could have two thoughts that you could
bring your argument to the full finance
committee on Tuesday afternoon or I
could add it to this the schedule for
Tuesday morning that would give us three
things to do in two hours
I won't as I stated earlier I won't be
here Tuesday morning but I entrust my
division members to properly um
communicate what I want to do with it so
would you prefer that we do talk about
it Tuesday Morning in division or do you
want to just go for it in full Finance
what's your what's your preference I'd
like to know if if this division would
be open to that discussion but we're not
discussing it now so I I think we're
open to discussing it we have a history
of bringing back prev previous committee
votes for reconsideration and I I think
this is consistent with the the
committee's precedent so I I'm I'm okay
bring it back if you're open to
discussing it Tuesday uh starting at
10:00 a.m. then I trust my my colleagues
here to defend my
Amendment okay and again I don't want to
have us discuss it now because it's not
on the house calendar okay
say I I I'm going to ask or do you know
can we can we get these three bills for
Tuesday morning uh not in the calendar
but you can get them publicly noticed
sure I I want them noticed properly not
in the house calendar announce the
recess make sure that there's a notice
door not yeah 499 is not part of the
recess because we're not talking about
it so thought we were finished we we are
but but there's there's a request to
reconsider $499 and we've done this
before so I I also think this being a
this being a division and not the full
committee you could informally decide to
uh reconsider a previous vote and it
wouldn't be a big deal would would would
it still be preferable to try to get an
online notice to notice it properly
sure do that I
I yeah we could put it on the door I
don't know yeah at a minimum it would go
on the door okay well whatever the
minimal standards are I want to meet or
exceed
those representative Mooney thank you is
there any idea what the fiscal note any
idea would be on this discussed
Amendment just
now uh for $499 it would be the HHS
piece was a little under 1.2 million in
total so the summary BT program was
about 1.1 million in fiscal
25 thank you and and does a fiscal note
refer to the potential of the 4.68
million of federal
money it doesn't no
okay all right uh did we leave anything
out that we should do Mr Ripple okay so
I'll take a motion to
adjourn second okay um no no discussion
so we are in recess just in case that's
the proper term until Tuesday Tuesday